[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda-yadda-yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was
and work tremendously to keep me pushing
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings the
studio experience right to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton calm that's o-n-e peloton PE l
oto and.com and enter the code Tim all
caps at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your pals from bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started this episode is brought to you
by Walter Isaacson's number one New York
Times best seller Leonardo da Vinci
which chronicles the life and times of
the renaissance genius while showing us
how we can harness da Vinci's boundless
curiosity in creativity
not long ago I interviewed Walter on
this podcast about his writing and
Leonardo as I've known Walter for some
time in the book is spectacular I think
it's his best biography yet and that is
really saying a lot considering how
famous and popular his bios are of
Benjamin Franklin Einstein and Steve
Jobs Leonardo da Vinci the book that is
has been hailed by the New Yorker as
quote a study in creativity how to
define it how to achieve it end quote
and it is based on thousands of pages
from Leonardo's astonishing notebooks
and new discoveries about his life and
work so Walter really reveals an
intimate Leonarda we get to know sides
of him we haven't seen before in a
narrative that connects his art to his
science he shows how Leonardo's genius
was based on skills that we can improve
in ourselves such as passionate
curiosity but how to hone that careful
observation how to develop it and an
imagination so playful that it even I
would say flirted with fantasy but at
the end of the day was eminently
practical Leonardo da Vinci by Walter
Isaacson published by Simon & Schuster
is available now wherever books are sold
and I suggest you check out an excerpt
at da Vinci bio.com
that's da Vinci bio.com
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this is a special episode and features
one of my very dear friends long-term
listeners know by now that a number of
my guests have started incredible
podcasts after being on this show as
their first ever podcast interview
including people like legendary Navy
SEAL commander Jocko willing what fewer
people know is that Jocko was introduced
to me by dr. Peter
attea you can find him on twitter and
instagram @ PT attea atti md and peter
is my conversational partner in today's
episode equally impressive in a lot of
respects he is a former ultra endurance
athlete for instance swimming races of
25 miles or more a compulsive self
experimenter so of course I love this
guy and one of the most fascinating
human beings
I know he is probably the highest end
doctor I have ever met and that's saying
a lot
specifically I would say I go to him
with questions about performance or our
longevity for instance would metformin
or rapamycin make sense to extend the
lifespan without sacrificing performance
etc etc but he is also easily the best
quarterback and Sherpa for the us
medical system I've ever encountered so
let me actually read some of his
official bio to do him justice Peter is
the founder of TIA medical PC a medical
practice with offices in San Diego and
New York City focusing on the applied
science of longevity peter trained for
five years at the johns hopkins hospital
in general surgery where he was the
recipient of several prestigious awards
including resident of the year and the
author of a comprehensive review of
general surgery he also spent two years
at the NIH as a surgical oncology fellow
at the National Cancer Institute where
his research focused on immune based
therapies for melanoma
he has since been mentored by some of
the most experienced an innovative lipid
ologists that's word endocrinologists
Gynaecologists sleep physiologists all
the ists
and longevity scientists forests in the
united states and canada peter earned
his MD from Stanford University and
holds a bachelor's of science and
mechanical engineering and applied
mathematics in the conversation in this
episode Peter actually interviews me
that's the plot twist though he shares a
lot of his own experiences and it is
audio from Peters incredible podcast
brand new the Peter Atia drive which can
be found on Apple podcast Spotify or
anywhere podcaster found it is one of
the few podcasts I listen to regularly
and many friends I've shared this
particular episode with this audio have
now listen to it in multiple times it
takes both Peter and I a few minutes to
warm up so there's a little bit of
cinnamon we call it a small talk for
play but then it goes really deep and we
end up talking about a lot of things
that people like Peter and I aren't
supposed to talk about publicly so with
that said here we go welcome to episode
1 of the Peter Atia Drive I can think of
no better person to begin this podcast
with than my very dear friend Tim
Ferriss not only is Tim a really close
friend but he's also almost
single-handedly the reason this podcast
is coming into existence so in other
words if you hate it you can blame Tim
tim has been kind of on my case for
about two years to do this and more than
anything else he's just really helped me
think about how I can sort of put
something together that allows me to
create something that is sort of new and
that isn't already out there in terms of
content but also is something that I'll
find enjoyable to do and that hopefully
will come across as this podcast gets
underway I'm guessing most people
listening to this know a lot about Tim
but on the off chance that there are
some who don't I think it's just worth
kind of giving a little bit of
background on Tim he's been described as
a quote a cross between Jack Welch and a
Buddhist monk by the New York Times
he's one of Fast Company's most
innovative businesspeople he's an
early-stage tech investor and advisor
and that includes a number of companies
that most people have heard of such as
uber Facebook Twitter Spotify Alibaba
and least 50 others he's also the
there are five number one New York Times
bestsellers and Wall Street Journal
bestsellers a 4-hour workweek the 4-hour
body the 4-hour chef tools of titans
also known as biggest tools that's an
inside joke in reference to the podcast
and tribe of mentors the observer and
other media outlets have described him
as the Oprah of audio due to the
influence of his podcast the Tim Ferriss
show which has about 300 million
downloads at the time of this recording
it's also been selected as the best of
iTunes for three years running now I
want to say something about this episode
that will become apparent obviously once
we get started one we talk a lot about
things that are topics that Tim and I
don't really spend a lot of time
discussing publicly and certainly
personally and so it's important to
understand here that while Tim and I do
talk quite openly about psychedelic
experiences we've shared in South
America it shouldn't be taken to mean
that that's what we're recommending that
anybody go out and do we're absolutely
not doing that there are physical there
are psychological and there are legal
risks among these things and it's
important to remember than the United
States at the time of this recording
psychedelics like psilocybin which we
speak about quite a bit
along with mescaline and things that we
don't get into much detail around such
as ayahuasca these are currently
schedule one which means that they are
illegal and while we believe obviously
that that designation is completely
unwarranted and will likely you know
eventually no longer be the case when
the scientific community has a chance to
catch up and understand the great
potential of these things really the
purpose of this podcast is informational
only and while I do generally provide a
disclaimer at the end of my podcast that
explains that all of this information is
informational I want to be really clear
about this particular issue we talk a
lot about these things we talked about a
few other things as well and I think
even for the listener who doesn't find
this topic to be particularly
interesting one thing that we talked
about at the very end of the podcast
that I'd been meaning to ask Tim for a
while and certainly I get asked a lot is
what are the things that you still
incorporate in your daily routine tim
has written so eloquently about this
stuff and has codified so many ways to
find these minimum effective doses and
to optimize everything he's doing that I
think people wonder hey which are the
things that have
really stood the test of time and so I
actually found that last part of the
podcast to be especially interesting
even for me though I knew these things
and I can see all the things that Tim
does day in and day out but to sort of
have him say look if I had to pick five
these would be the five Tim can be found
all over the place but I think the best
place is to see him are on his blog
which is Tim dot blog you can follow him
at T Ferriss that's fer Riss on Twitter
and you find him at Tim Ferriss on
Facebook and Instagram I hope you enjoy
this first episode half as much as I
enjoyed recording it and there will be
lots more of these to follow so with all
of that said please welcome Tim Ferriss
hey Tim Peter thank you for having me on
Austin this weekend my pleasure it's
been a good weekend
good view too yeah what I can't believe
is in the relatively short period of
time you have lived here you've become
essentially the unofficial mayor of
Austin I like to get involved and to
explore all the various nooks and
crannies of any city that I live in and
after 17 years in the Bay Area I felt
like I had left almost no stone unturned
have many dear friends are still there
but many of them have traveled outside
and one of the places that was an annual
migration was South by Southwest here in
Austin and had wanted to move here right
after college gotten to know it
year by year with increasingly longer
stays in the city before and after the
festival itself and now it's home
couldn't be happier feel like every
place we went in the last three days
everybody knew you like the owner the
restaurant would know you and in the
coffee shop and there's I don't think
I've drank more coffee and topo Chico in
a short period of time that's a yes
coffee topo Chico and so many things
here yeah breakfast tacos is something I
haven't yet explored that's another form
of religion here right next to barbecue
and a bunch of other things
but it's a cozy feel it has a
neighborhood feel and I've come to value
that type of neighborhood feel and
cohesion which is something I probably
wouldn't have paid much attention to ten
years ago yeah I've sort of always
assumed I would live forever in
California and I kind of say all your
hard work here to get your friends to
move out here it's I think it's kind of
payoff I I think I can see Austin in my
future yeah I have a life a lot of
friends who are moving and I think in
many respects its defined by the fact
that it's difficult to categorize there
is no one mono conversation about tech
or entertainment or finance and some
people might view that as a weakness
meaning if you're looking to live in the
epicenter of a certain industry and
you're in your early 20s and want to cut
your teeth and live that hyperkinetic
super aggressive lifestyle while you're
building your foundation for the future
that's one thing but in my case I'm much
more so and placing value on the general
friendliness the cultural diversity
which is not just skin deep it covers so
many different bases here and I enjoy
the fact that you can go from a strict
vegan restaurant to a deer processing
plant to an electric scooter startup
office to a cowboy boot store all in the
stretch of a few blocks that's exciting
to me and though I've never really
bought the argument that people in New
York and southern California which are
the two places I spend most of my time
are you know more about the argument
that those are snotty super snotty
places and nobody's nice because I do
think that people are actually pretty
decent everywhere and including in the
middle of Manhattan but that said it's a
different level of nice here that is
completely foreign to me yeah it is I
remember when I first moved to Austin
and I had a number of neighbors drop off
cards or come to the door to ring the
bell to ask if I want to come over for
dinner
and I didn't even know how to respond
which which really you're like what do
they sell me more about myself that I
was so mistrusting perhaps but in San
Francisco that does not happen as far as
I know I've never heard of that
happening certainly in New York mm-hmm
it'd be you know time to check your
security system and and consider your
your avenues of getting out of the house
but here that's just par for the course
and it's it's really been nice to
embrace that and even within Texas
Austin is is known for being very very
friendly and I've met many different
people here who've moved from Houston in
other parts which are also fantastic in
their own way
because of the general level of
friendliness something I'm a fan you
know I always thought I would be felt
the gravitational pull here when I
graduated and did not get the job here
that I was so coveted at trilogy and it
turned out being a blessing disguise
that I didn't get the job and I think
also for trilogy because I I most likely
would have been a terrible employee
but that took me to NorCal had a great
stint there but that chapter came to a
close and it was just the right time
well as I said it's been amazing to be
here not my first time here but each
time I come I I like it more and more
and I guess with that said we are
kicking off effectively the first
episode of a podcast that you more than
any other friend although several
friends have played an enormous role in
the so called cajoling as I referred to
it earlier in making this happen so if
this ends up sucking I'll take all the
blame I'm blaming you
yeah if this ends up doing okay I'm
thanking you but either way I think this
has been this will be fun I think my
customary thirty percent is very
reasonable thirty percent of water right
now obviously this podcast is on some
level and probably on a large level
going to come down to things that I
think a lot about and hope to bring to
people you asked me the other day you
know what am i hoping to accomplish with
this and I don't have a great elevator
pitch on it but one of the things
is I find myself so often having
conversations with people that I think
God this person so much smarter than me
and knows so much more than me and
they're letting me be a sponge right now
and absorb so much information from them
and so many times I find myself at the
end of those discussions thinking I
can't believe nobody else got to hear
that what if I didn't extract everything
from that correctly what if there was
more to be gathered and so it's really
that desire to sort of have as many of
these conversations as possible and be
able to sort of share them in their
natural state that I think is a large
part of this motivation and while most
people sort of associate me I suspect
with thinking about longevity we
probably don't spend enough time talking
about what longevity means but the way I
talk about it with my patients is it's
both enhancing lifespan but also a
health span and life span is the easier
of those two to understand because
enhancing lifespan just means not dying
which is not to say that that's easy but
it's conceptually easy I think the
health spans stuff is harder to
understand and as I have come to learn
in the past three or four years I
believe for most people it actually
matters more many people think you know
if you helping me
doesn't add one day to the length of my
life but improves the quality of my life
especially at the end that would be
sufficient and so in many ways I what I
want to talk about today is one piece of
health span that I I know the least
about by far but also I think is the one
that we are least likely to talk about
as a society which is sort of mental
health now you've spoken really publicly
about your interest in that I knew a lot
of this before you talked about it at
Ted but can you tell me a little bit
about that I can and I'm thrilled you're
doing a podcast because I do think that
just as as a bit of Overland what you
said there is so much focus on extending
life span rightly so but the equal
obsession equal level of obsession that
you bring to performance and health span
I think creates a compelling combination
that I don't find in many places I find
the combination of those interests very
common but the combination of
competencies broadly speaking in both of
those domains is very uncommon
I'm excited to listen to other episodes
of the podcast and as it relates to
mental health I should as maybe a
introductory preamble say that this is
not a topic I've always been comfortable
talking about publicly and in fact I
would say for the vast majority of my
adolescence and certainly throughout
high school and college I somehow came
to the conclusion that I was just not
designed to be happy that evolution did
not optimize for happiness and I just
did not have the code for happy and that
was okay that I would be an instrument
of competition I would learn to be good
at various things that were valued at
colleges and then by the business worlds
and so on and that it was not worth
trying to be happy or to not just love
myself but really have a high opinion of
myself and in fact that was
self-indulgent and that I would just
focus on being the best competitor
possible and hopefully turning that into
something that was not only a value to
me or that I was rewarded for but that
would help other people and that perhaps
I would find some joy in the joy of
other people but that was the extent of
it and suffered from many different
bouts of extended depression for as long
as I can recall really and that is also
something that you can spot very easily
looking back at my family history on
both sides and if you look back to
grandparents and great-great
grandparents a fair amount of alcohol
consumption certainly a fair amount of
alcoholism I thankfully have not soothe
myself with excessive amounts of alcohol
but you see a lot of patterns that
scared me certainly but the depression
was one that I could just not seemingly
navigate around and the TED talk opened
with a particularly close call the
closest call I've ever had this is
not a common experience for me but in
college where I can very very close to
killing myself and we actually got to
the planning stages it wasn't just
rumination about what if I wonder what
it would be like take my life no it
would it was a decision that had been
made and I was already in the planning
stages and to give people the short
punchline to that which explains why I'm
here today
I had reserved a book which was going to
be the last of many that I had read on
this subject related to suicide it was
already checked out of the firestone
library Princeton Rose at the time
taking a year away from and it was
checked out to some other poor student
so I put in a request to be notified
when it came back into the library but I
forgot to update my dress at the
Registrar's Office and the address that
I had on file after taking this leave of
absence was my home address in New York
where my parents lived and so my mom got
this postcard which was dear Tim Ferriss
this is to notify you that and then
whatever it was you know the final
solution da-da-da-da-da whatever might
have been the how to kill yourself
manual has arrived please come to claim
your book within the next X number of
weeks or I'll be released to the next
person who has it on reservation
whatever the postcard said and I got
this very heartfelt understandably
nervous call from my mom with her voice
cracking asking about it and I lied I
said it was I was very fast on my feet
and I said it was for a friend Rutgers
who wasn't able to get the book for a
dissertation or thesis he was working on
so I reserved it for him no everything's
fine but in that moment after that call
I realized how these in retrospect
little waves small events can be blown
or even large events can be blown so out
of proportion or seen as permanent in
such a way that regardless of
socioeconomic status regardless of race
regardless of gender people can be so
knocked off course that they end up
taking their own lives and certainly
recently that's been
very dramatically demonstrated and
tragically demonstrated with the deaths
of many people including Anthony
Bourdain who comes to mind most recently
and that's just on the the high-profile
side but in my case personally I
realized how my blinders and pessimism
and this downward spiral had led me to
really only focus on my pain I didn't
realize how until that phone call
committing suicide would have been like
taking ten times the pain that I felt
and imposing it on the people who loved
me the most and that was a huge wake-up
call so that is why I'm here today is
the lucky accident that I did not update
my address at the registrar's office and
if that had not happened I mean I was
ready to pull the trigger so to speak
although that wasn't how I was going to
go but it was all spec down it's
terrifying to think of really really
terrifying thing of and I have some of
my best friends in high school who you
never would have suspected from the
outside looking in killed themselves
College same story I just know so many
people who have taken their own lives
and it always came as a shock to people
at least who knew them in school for
instance they seemed to have it all
together they seemed to have the good
relationship or the good job or the good
grades or whatever it might be the good
family and that's led me in the last few
years in particular to at the very least
want to focus on discussing mental
health different facets of mental health
from an experiential first-hand basis
simply to tell people if assuming I
don't have any type of ready answer for
them you are not alone this is
exceptionally exceptionally common but
it's the dirty little secret that so
many people carry around and are
unwilling to discuss and so at the very
least I want to say you are not alone
there are millions upon millions of
people fighting similar battles and
everyone you meet is fighting
some inner battle you know nothing about
so do not assume that you were alone and
I think in that hopefully people can
find some solace and then beyond that
I've spent the last few years really
investigating using the contacts and
network that I've developed through the
books and the podcast and the tech
investing to explore avenues and
potential treatments or interventions
that can certainly help people who are
on the brink get back to stability
potentially but also to take people who
are who might view themselves as stable
or normal and to mitigate against the
potential of losing their footing and
then there are we can go beyond that
certainly but that is the my interest in
this certainly began on a very personal
level how do I is it possible I should
say forget about how is it possible for
me to manage this and the type of
thinking that triggers the most
dangerous downward spirals is what's the
point if I'm if I'm constantly going to
default to this negative thinking and
I'm so blessed for a B and C reasons
what's the point and that is a really
really poisonous toxic mental landscape
to immerse yourself into it and get
caught in so is it possible for me to
somehow decrease the frequency of those
types of episodes is it possible somehow
to decrease the severity of those
episodes is it possible to look at my
quirky biochemistry my software in a way
that I see some blessings within my
day-to-day month-to-month experience
then someway counteract the tendency to
view myself so harshly when the
inevitable dips come long answer to a
short question but that's that's really
been particularly in the last I would
say two years three mostly starting
about five years ago but in the last two
or three really diverting
a lot of my attention that was going to
startup investing a lot of my resources
that were going to startup investing to
areas that are related to this and
there's so much of that stuff I can't
wait to talk about today because you've
brought a lot of people along on this
ride with you so obviously I can only
speak from my own personal experience
but we have so many mutual friends who
have also been heavily influenced by
sort of a sense of awareness that you've
brought to us with respect to all of
these things but also potential solution
spaces that are outside of our realm of
thinking you know you said something at
the outset which was you just thought
you weren't wired to be happy which I I
mean I can resonate with that completely
I remember as a child my mom would
always say to me you know Peter do you
just not want to be happy and I would
look at her like I don't know what kind
of dumb question that is like it's not
an option like you might as well be
asking me if I want to be 12 feet tall
like I have some say in the matter
it's not about wanting to be happy it's
just about metaphysically not being able
to be happy and then furthermore my
thought which was even a bit more
obscure or maybe bizarre was happiness
was a bad thing because you would stop
being hungry makes you complacent yes so
right along with self-indulgence there
was that yeah it was like mom if I was
happy I wouldn't get up at 4:30 in the
morning and run harder and faster than
anybody else - and of course I didn't
have the I don't think I'd the mental
framework to probe that idea further
which is what are you proving who are
you proving it to why do you feel the
need to do all of these things but it
wasn't until quite recently that I even
began to entertain the idea that being
happy is not a bad thing or put another
way that it's a good thing yeah the
double negative yeah right just to touch
on a few things you just mentioned - I
think are really important
the self-talk Jim Lehrer who's a
performance coach who has worked with
many many of the most famous tennis
players and other athletes in the world
I had a chance to spend time with him
for my last book and then also for some
tennis training in Florida and he spent
time with one of my very close friends
Josh Waitzkin as well who's who's best
known for being the basis for searching
for Bobby Fischer for those people are
familiar and
talks a lot about the inner voice the
most important coach and voice you ever
hear is your inner voice so I've learned
to pay increasing attention to the words
I use particularly when I'm ruminating
referring to myself talking to myself
making a note to self that's a long
story inside joke guys another time and
I found myself using perhaps very
unsurprisingly similar language to
yourself if I were happy I wouldn't be
doing the things that are very clearly
contributing to my success whatever that
means and not only that but on every
possible level if I were to find joy in
too many moments or to not feel
deficient or inadequate or loads low the
wordly which is honestly how I felt for
the majority of my life no I don't just
not love myself like there's a deep
sense of well I hate to use the word
hate but it's the right word like
loathing like how could you be so stupid
how can you be so lazy how could you be
so fill in the blank toughen the [ __ ] up
and you may not have control over all
things but you know you can get really
really good at doing is absorbing pain I
get really good at absorbing pain it's
like okay if you work hard and have a
high pain tolerance maybe you can win
maybe you can be successful and I should
put win and successful and quotation
marks because they're so seldom well
defined by people who use this type of
language including myself for decades
but what I've come to realize and this
this is also a I think a common concern
among type-a personalities who consider
or are told by people they respect that
they should take a stab at meditation
for a period of time there is this
highly prevalent almost universal
concern among type-a personalities by
which I just mean driven like
hard-charging head through walls I can
take the pain [ __ ] it I'm just going to
grit my teeth and white-knuckle through
anything that comes my way which hey
let's let's face it that serves people
very well up to a point in certain ways
they worry about losing their edge this
is the exact wording that I hear so
often in the exact wording that I use
with my friends when they first
recommended a few of them Rick Rubin and
Chase Jarvis very specifically Rick
Rubin legendary music producer although
that doesn't eat it's not even a drop in
the ocean of what Rick does and who Rick
is but Rick Rubin and then chase very
very famous photographer also the CEO of
a company called creative live which is
an incredible company in and of itself
both of them recommended meditation to
me and I resisted for more than a year I
want to say because I was afraid of
losing my edge even though what I came
to realize was if you want to use your
edge indiscriminantly like a kitchen
knife which is only a blade front like
the handle is also bladed on both sides
you can continue doing what you're doing
if on the other hand you want to put a
nice ergonomic handle on that
beautifully hard blade so that you can
use it as an instrument before it's its
highest purposes you can utilize
different tools meditation being one of
them and we could talk about all the
different types of meditation as well
because I think they do have slightly
different applications is a tool in the
tool kit that allows you to build this
beautiful kitchen knife instead of
holding on to the blade itself just
bleeding over and over again scabbing
bleeding scabbing bleeding which is I
think day to day how many driven people
experienced life whether they are
financially stable or not if they are
compulsively active if they are using
the distraction of constant motion and
absorbing pain and seeking pain to numb
themselves so that they don't have to be
in their own head any longer than
possible which is what I did
for a [ __ ] long time pardon my french
but I mean decades
if they're able to develop other skills
that allow them to and I've certainly
less less than seeking happiness I have
been looking for ways to both develop in
myself and help others to develop a
sense of peace even if it's ten minutes
a day that that does nothing nothing
negative in my book other than magnify
your strengths and allow you to maybe
for the first time see some of your
weaknesses that are very often
self-imposed and the blind spots that
have been like an invisible hand guiding
your life for in some cases decades
I see no I really see no downside to
that and since I've had two cappuccinos
and I guess have some extra personality
I'll further extend my long-ass answer
by saying my books very clearly track my
priorities in some respects you have the
4-hour workweek which looked at
different types of currencies time being
the most valuable non-renewable of those
and how to address a few rungs on
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and as I've
moved along and suffered my own burnout
of different types not necessarily
financially related but certainly for
our chef took me out for the count I bit
off more than I could chew in part
because I was having some personal
difficulties and some relationships and
I wanted to know myself I went back to
that numbing behavior which included
taking stimulants which included over
caffeinated in addition to the pills and
so on using alcohol at night to wind
down engaging in exercise that was far
more painful and ridiculously punishing
than it had to be for any type of health
or performance purpose and I crashed and
burned and that led to the podcast as a
way to take a break from book writing
which led to the explorations and
talking to people like Brene brown
talking to people like Tara brach
talking to people like jack Kornfield
and many many others that then led to
say tribal mentors or tools of titans
then tribal mentors and where I am now
where I look at this Maslow's hierarchy
of needs and realize at least for myself
let's say you cover your food you cover
your shelter you cover that then you get
up to these rungs on the ladder where
you've checked off success you are
blessed you are
hopefully healthy your family might be
healthy and you can meet all of your
basic needs and probably have some
disposable income and yet you have
trouble living with yourself that's a
[ __ ] tragedy I mean it's to have
deciphered how to achieve and yet not be
able to appreciate is that it's just the
tragedy of tragedies it's this kind of
fool's errand that could have taken five
years could have taken ten could have
taken 20 and then you see people like
that who do not know which way to turn
and then perhaps just withdraw into a
shell and you know sit at a table with
their family and look at their phone for
the entire dinner over and over and over
again because they don't know how to
emotionally engage with themselves let
alone other people or you see the more
dramatic cases where they're like all
right I thought these things would make
me happy I was told these things were
the necessary ingredients for eventually
solving this emotional Rubik's Cube that
I've been struggling with my whole life
where I assumed that poof one day I
would just wake up and have made it even
if having made it just means you're not
struggling with alcoholism and rent like
your parents did or something like that
and I've come to realize you don't need
to and you should not wait until you
think you have all of the other pieces
non-emotional non psychological pieces
the puzzle together to start working on
self-acceptance among other things and
untying some of those Gordian knots that
you have that you might have carried for
decades since your childhood and that it
is not esoteric it is not intangible
when you start to address some of those
things it makes everything more
effortless it makes everything more
rewarding and that I think is a project
worth tackling it's a lot but that's
yeah this this depression I think
particularly among men who are very very
very bad generally and I'm just gonna
paint with a broad brush because that
makes this type of conversation a little
easier but broadly speaking cross across
cultures it really doesn't matter where
you go women are generally better at
social cohesion and building groups of
friends who are mutually supportive and
we look at it through an evolutionary
lens but men very often are biologically
culturally who knows fill-in-the-blank
trained and may be born to just bite
their lip and suffer in silence and I do
think there are certain places for that
look if you're gonna be a Navy SEAL
commander waking up every morning and
like telling the your direct reports
like about your really hard dream you've
had probably not like strategically
tactically professionally or ethically
the right thing to do when you have to
go out and then risk your lives doing
things that are mission-critical to fill
in the blank right so there there is a
time for that but to make that your one
coping mechanism for navigating life or
like the sort of the mesh that is
imposed on everything else that you
suffer in silence
and that the solution to that is just to
get tougher to get better at accepting
pain to use cheesy tech parlance doesn't
scale it just doesn't scale you know
when I was on your podcast the first
time which I don't know how long ago
that was it feels like it's probably
been three or four years ago one of the
questions I remember you asked in which
of course you asked many of your guests
is what book have you gifted more than
any other and I remember the book I
mentioned at the time it was and remains
a great book but I now have to update
that answer what wasn't just for people
who were curious
it was mistakes were made but not
me which is just an amazing book on the
psychology of cognitive dissonance but
of course that now has been surpassed
there is now a new book that is my most
gifted book and amazing that I can't
believe I didn't bring a copy to Austin
to give you because I now I probably I
think I just by Amazon out of this book
like I just have stacks of it all over
like you have stacks of certain books in
your place and this book is called I
don't want to talk about it by Terence
reel who have since reading the book and
becoming obsessed with actually it comes
back to you you introduced me to Esther
Perel Esther recommended the book the
book was one of a series of little
nudges that ultimately led to me meeting
Terry and of course that book has now
been the book I have given most but what
you said is spot-on which is there is
just this epidemic of male depression
and it's not always overt that's the
thing right people have this image of
what depression is but you know like a
guy who's constantly angry or
emotionally volatile he can be quite
depressed so depression isn't always
dysthymia and I think that's where
people miss this idea of how much pain
people both men and women carry around
but how men have this more orthogonal
way of displaying it that makes it get
masked longer and longer and I wanna go
back to something you said earlier
because it really hit home about a year
ago when a mutual friend of ours Paul
Conte made this point to me which was
the way you treat yourself is ultimately
how you will treat those you love most
and you know when he really pushed me to
think about that which is do you want to
be the guy who treats his kids the way
you treat yourself and it had to be put
that way for me to think no I mean if
I'm gonna be brutally honest I would not
want to watch my kids get treated by
another human the way I treat myself
even though I think it's good for me to
treat myself this way so again I think
the challenge is by far the hardest part
is getting people to accept that maybe
what they're doing isn't the right thing
or is it maybe writes the wrong word a
it's not the best thing it's not the
optimal thing I loved your analogy of
taking the best blade in the world and
not having a handle on it I mean it's a
limited tool yeah and there are so I
would say just to maybe put a fine point
on it going through life merely
tolerating yourself which would have
been a dream for me I mean I I actively
loathed myself and any weakness any
mistake any foible any flaw I was I was
and and and still at times I'm so
incredibly violently critical in my own
head that it is not the treatment I
would want to that I would wish on
anyone I care about that is not a state
you have to accept it is not programming
that you have to accept and there are
ways to begin to chip away at that and
to rewire it and to reformat in a sense
certain behaviors that you've
experienced for so long many of them our
thought patterns self-talk that you've
come to believe they're completely
unchangeable and in my experience and
more and more the experience of dozens
and thousands of other people I've
observed in the last five years it is is
patent it is patently untrue that you
have to accept that and I think what you
said is really really important to
digest and ponder and that is how you
treat yourself as how you were going to
treat the people you care most about and
I think it was actually Gloria Steinem
about a quote I don't know if this is
accurate but somebody on the internet
I'm sure will fact check this who said
in effect I'm paraphrasing here but the
goal you have to remember that the
Golden Rule goes both ways so we all
know do unto others as you would have
them do unto you if you flip that around
it is do unto yourself as you would do
unto others and that is really has very
profound and why
reaching implications and when you
really sit with it for a minute and
spice to say though you do not have to
accept the inner voice are the patterns
that have led you to pursue success with
rare glimpses of any type of inner peace
that that is not something you have to
accept so one of the most sort of
profound experiences I've had sets of
experiences I've had in the past few
years our experiences we've shared
together around certain plants that
honestly I was completely unaware of an
ignorant of for most of my life had
never really given them any thought and
probably much of the stuff that you've
talked about written about in the past
in particular there were two podcasts
that you did one was with Martin and I'm
trying to the Argentine Polanco and Dan
angle Dan angle that was the other one
yeah and those were two separate podcast
but they were very close together if I
recall there couple months there were a
few together and then a few apart so you
had James Fadiman and then dan angle and
Martine together that's right
and then later Michael Pollan yeah but
that first wave was probably 2015 issue
yeah it was a few years ago that was the
thin end of the wedge and interestingly
the thin end of the wedge for me was
around something that wasn't a personal
issue but more of a societal issue which
is I was blown away by the discussion
and the clinical results that they were
achieving in Mexico using a plant called
AI boga and using out ibogaine as well
to treat patients who were opiate
addicted and that's something that even
back when I was sort of you know in my
residency and you would see in a city
like Baltimore what the effects of
heroin addiction are and of course today
it's even a much bigger issue and it's
spread far beyond just heroin
so that just interested me purely for an
intellectual standpoint which is wait a
minute we have a drug or set of drugs
that are so categorically addictive to
so many for which our only treatments
are at best useless and
there's this other thing that admittedly
comes with plenty of risk and plenty of
unknowns but it seems to fundamentally
change the way a person's brain is wired
which would seem to address the root
issue as opposed to the band-aid that
led of course to me wanting to
understand more about those entire
classes of compounds and that led to my
very first experience with them which I
shared with you meaning which you know
you helped me through which to this day
remains one of the most profound things
I've ever done and if anybody's
listening to this who's thinking what
are they talking about what are these
psychedelic agents aren't those drugs
you know all these things one of the
most remarkable things I remember after
the first time I tried psilocybin was I
don't feel like doing that again any
time soon like these are the most anti
addictive compounds on the planet what
started your interest into that space
the interest began and for those people
listening who are wondering if if we'll
discuss any other tools I think we
should also discuss some other options
on the table aside from this although
this is very fertile ground for
discussions so we can talk about
meditation some other tools and books
and so on later but the my interest in
psychedelics began long ago with a close
friend who introduced me to psilocybin
it contained in what is commonly called
magic mushrooms must have been in
college midpoint perhaps in college and
it became an annual ritual and once a
year I would meet up with a few of my
closest friends and we would consume
mushrooms in retrospect it was very
haphazard we were not measuring any
doses just to have a big bag of
mushrooms and split it up and then hope
for the best which is not ideally how
you go about things and nonetheless
despite the lack of controls and I do
not recommend anyone use these compounds
under uncontrolled circumstances
I experienced what I began to refer to
as a reboot and I would have this
anxiety and depression plaguing me I
would go very very deep and looking back
now I was almost certainly consuming
minimum of five grams I'm sure I was
consuming quite a high dose of mushrooms
which is for those people who might read
the the writing or listen to some of the
presentations of someone named Terence
Mckenna five grams is referred to as a
heroic dose and that is a dose
sufficient to flatten even the most
resistant ego I believe is the wording
that was used in any case I felt this
decrease or even complete removal of
depression anxiety that extended far
beyond the supposed duration of effect
let's just call it five to eight hours
and there would be this afterglow period
that certainly lasted most acutely for a
day or two after the experience and I
was going into this also with none of
the best practices that we know of now
in terms of preparation intention
setting perhaps some of the preparatory
steps you could take and then
integration there's none of that so this
was very bare-bones haphazard
experimentation with few friends
nonetheless there were these periods of
let's just call it two weeks to two
months where I was able to finally see
things clearly appreciate all of the
incredible chance blessings that I
experienced in my life and make
decisions about things I viewed as
serious problems or challenges or
opportunities whether it was making a
decision about academics making a
decision about a relationship to either
start a relationship or end a
long-standing relationship these were
things I was able to look at very calmly
and make decisions about and ultimately
after I want to say four or five years
of this had a very very very scary and
dangerous
experience which was again with no
sitters in other words no sober person
supervising this any number of things
can go wrong and one is people can
wander around and get themselves into
dangerous situations in my case I ended
up coming out of my trip very late at
night walking on the side of a street
with cars whizzing by me I mean that
could have very easily been the end and
that scared me enough that I stopped I
said never again too dangerous and I
stopped
I didn't revisit psychedelics until
let's just call it let's think about
this 10 to 15 years later when a
girlfriend at the time who had some very
very very difficult traumatic
experiences as a child travel to Peru
which has its own set of very real risks
that we can talk about if we would like
if you were going down explicitly for
the purpose of using a psychedelic most
commonly in this case ayahuasca but her
experience was strong enough and
meaningful enough that she came back and
said to me that she wished it for me
because it was like 15 years of therapy
and two nights now if anyone knows
anything about any of the books I've
written or the way that I tend to view
the world that is a very very effective
sales pitch for Tim 15 years of therapy
and two nights interesting and I put
that in the back of my mind did not move
ahead with it because of my fear relate
which I think was very it was
well-founded I had a what could have
been a very very dangerous experience or
fatal experience things had to get much
worse for me to finally decide to
re-enter that world which I did first
through a guided psilocybin experience I
did not want to go straight to ayahuasca
which I to this day believe is a very
very big gun and can be very
destabilizing
I didn't want to go I didn't want that
to be my reintroduction so I did I had
one guided psilocybin experience which
also lacked much in terms of any type of
prep integration or post so it was
effective in the sense that it it was
like a returning home and it was a
familiar feeling that I came out of
unscathed
I took an absurdly high dose because I
didn't know what I had taken before so
for those people who know anything about
it I began at seven and a half and they
did a booster a nine which for me is it
is such an absurd overkill series to
almost defy belief at this point which
by the way is a counterproductive taking
too much is counterproductive it is not
more is better by any stretch of the
imagination being strapped to the
Icebreaker is not as very rarely what
someone needs in any case came out of
its realizing that you could approach
this in a safer fashion with a container
physical and otherwise that allowed you
to avoid the risk I had that it scared
me off then went into the ayahuasca
experience about six months perhaps six
months later took it very seriously had
people sign non-disclosure agreements
had someone act as my proxy to try to
vet people in several different
countries and ultimately honed in on
someone I spent two nights with and it
was one of the most disorienting on
spiring experiences of my life without
question the first night I was prepared
for all of the sickness and vomiting and
terror that I knew could be part of the
experience and it was blissful it was an
incredible first night second night was
without any exaggeration the most
painful experience of my life at one
point I experienced full-body seizures
it's a grand mall
controlled uncontrollable seizures for
about I would estimate two and a half
hours ended up with rug burns all over
my face and hands and feet and was
completely lost there was no contact no
footing in this reality whatsoever and
my subjective felt experience was one of
being torn apart a thousand times a
second dying a thousand times a second
only to reman efest and have that repeat
infinitum
it was beyond horror and when I came out
of the experience or the main roller
coaster was was coasting to an end after
let's call it six to eight hours I was I
was partially detached from reality for
probably 36 hours and I had very
fortunately paid someone in advance to
babysit me and act as a chaperone for
that extended period in the off chance
that it happened which accept being the
case and the entire time as soon as I
was coherent enough to even think in
English which took a while I thought
never again never again will I touch
anything like this and it was only six
to eight weeks later and I should
mention that my intention I did have an
intention this time going in to the
second night specifically which was to
let go of anger towards myself towards
other people very handful of very
specific people and I swore I would
never touch this stuff again it was just
too scary - potentially dangerous I
thought there was a real chance that I
could lose my mooring from a sanity
perspective and never come back and I
realized six to eight weeks later after
spending a lot of time with someone I've
known forever who have I've had a very
contentious emotionally volatile
relationship with lots of triggers
things I thought were beyond repair
meaning couldn't spend more than an hour
with this person without feeling extreme
agitation and anger well up in some
fashion and I had I had given up on that
changing that long ago I realized let's
just call it six weeks after my two
nights that 90% of that was gone with
this person and completely gone and to
this day it has not come back and that
has repeated itself or I've seen that in
a number of my closest relationships the
value of that is hard to overemphasize
it's hard to even put into words and
it's so far outside any conceptual
schema in medicine or therapy that I've
run into it's it's hard to convey in a
way that makes any sense
because I've had so many people ask me
well how did that happen
I do not have a good explanation for
that all I do know is since then having
explored this both on an experiential
level having spent time in several
countries working with people who are
some of the best at what they do and I
do think I'm very very good at vetting
that hopefully people believe that after
looking at the books and the podcast and
so on I'm really good at getting a hold
of people who are really really good and
I'm very good at vetting and having
explored the space also from a
scientific standpoint it just gets more
interesting it just gets more
unbelievable
yet at the same time compelling and some
some of the changes I have seen in
people are they defy explanation by any
conventional means and I'll throw in a
few examples but before I throw out the
examples I want to make it really clear
that these compounds are not for
everyone
there are contraindications things can
go wrong and they're not a panacea they
do not fix everything by
any stretch of the imagination but for
certain types of debilitating conditions
thought patterns and fear they are
remarkable really really impressive to
the point that it is outside of the care
and feeding and love of my family and
myself my closest friends it is what I'm
I am most focused on furthering from a
scientific standpoint certainly so you
and another friend who is a mutual
friend of ours so it's all this big
circle of people we know but shared an
equally remarkable story with me about a
single experience he had had in this
case it was psilocybin as opposed to
ayahuasca that also took him to this
place of you know incredible emotional
pain that led to a change in a belief in
this case it was for this individual it
was it was a belief system around a
person who was no longer alive so
someone they had lost
I will never probably forget my first
experience with psilocybin for the same
reason it's interesting I I didn't know
that that experience you described came
from your very second time with
ayahuasca I was familiar with that story
because you'd shared it with me before
but hadn't pegged it to such an early
time but my first experience with
psilocybin if not for the fact that I
had that experience I wouldn't know what
the hell you were talking about right
now because it seems so improbable
implausible and impossible that
something that occurs over a span of six
or eight hours that is nothing more than
these compounds that come from these
plants could so fundamentally alter the
way we interact with other people in my
case it was very similar it was a very
important person in my life for whom I'd
not had a great relationship in a very
long time because I simply had no
empathy now Michael Pollan has written
about this so eloquently and I I wish I
could even have to reiterate what he
said because I remember him writing
about it going that's exactly it which
is for the first time in your life or at
least for me I'm not seeing the world
through my eyes anymore and David Foster
Wallace's
talked about this so eloquently in his
talk which is one of my favorite talks
this is water every experience we have
is through our own eyes and these plants
give you that ability to be out of that
and Iram remember watching myself as a
13 year old boy in this situation and
for the first time ever not seeing that
situation from my vantage point instead
seeing it from the vantage point of
others and that led to the most profound
emotional breakdown which again these
are very durable changes I mean I'm a
couple of years out of this but I truly
believe that 40 years from now I will
still have this exact set of feelings
about this particular individual and
this particular experience and you're
right there is I how do you explain that
it's very difficult and these compounds
many of the classic psychedelics let's
just for the sake of argument we'll
leave LSD out of the running for a
number of reasons including just the the
political PR baggage that that acronym
carries if we're looking at say
mescaline which is found in peyote it's
found in the San Pedro or watchu a
macaque tiss in South America among
other places and we're looking at
psilocybin found in quite a few
different mushrooms these are compounds
that have been used for hundreds of
years probably millennia by different
civilizations and you have Amanita
muscaria which was used in Europe you
have psychedelics that have been used
all over the world psychedelics
referring to and there's there are
different ways to try to define this
term but mind manifesting is what the
word refers to if you look at the
etymology but I would say experientially
one of the defining characteristics of
psychedelics and we probably will talk
about we might have the chance to talk
about MDMA later which is in some way
can be used for us for many of the same
conditions but I wouldn't consider a
psychedelic simply because psychedelics
provide what is often referred to at
high enough dosages ego dissolution or a
controlled death experience where you
cease to exist as the subject who is
viewing your experience of reality that
is so powerful that I again it we talk
about it with these sort of in this sort
of banal way but until you experience
that that statement is so difficult to
come it is imagine so imagine if you
will and they're there different
analogies or metaphors you can use but
imagine if your whole life you have been
the protagonist at least in your own
mind you are the primary actor in the
play of your life and you've always been
the primary actor in the play of your
life there are other actors of course
all these people you've ever met and for
the first time you realize that it's a
play and you're sitting in the audience
and you're the playwright you're the
person who has the ability to look at it
from every perspective and you can
change the lines of the primary actor
that person known as Tim in my case that
person known as Peter if you want to
change their lines you want to change
their backstory you want to change the
stories they tell themselves you have
the ability to do that because you're
sitting in the audience as an observer
of this person who is known as Peter or
Tim and this is similar to the type of
experience that people can have through
meditation and they might describe it as
instead of being outside standing in the
storm you're standing inside looking
through the window at the storm or you
are instead of being inside the washing
machine you're zooming out 18 inches so
that you're looking into the washing
machine and you're observing what is
happening as opposed to being tumbled by
it and in fact the the state's achieved
through psychedelics and in very
experienced meditators although I'm
convinced that you can achieve this
state pretty quickly through meditation
it doesn't have to take 20 years is
remarkably similar as best we know or
there are some similarities I should say
neurophysiological II in the sense that
if seemed to not necessarily deactivate
but decrease activity in something
referred to as the default mode Network
and this default mode Network and Peter
you may do a better job of explaining
this michael pollan does a fantastic job
of describing this in his book how to
change your mind which I recommend to
everyone
yeah well link to the book will also
link to your interview with Michael
recently which was excellent as well
even if people say they're not quite
ready to read the book at the very least
they should invest the time and listen
to the podcast and by the way I would
not suggest that anyone jump out and
tomorrow go on Craigslist to try to find
a shaman to take you through some
experience even if you felt like that
was an inevitable step you ultimately
want to take there are some things that
I would recommend first that can by
themselves be exceptionally
exceptionally useful so to come back to
it though the ability to for the first
time view this ego that refers to itself
in my case as Tim who is a combination
of many different things the identity
that we have had voiced it upon us or
conditioned into us but also that we've
created for ourselves by the stories we
tell ourselves that we've always told
ourselves oh my you know my wife always
does this my dad always does that I
always do this I never do that these
stories that we've told ourselves so
long that we've come to accept it as
just a fiber in our being to look at it
and realize that you can reformat almost
every part of that or you can take
trauma that you experienced as a child
and for the first time ever
recontextualize it as an adult without
emotion to look at it with a level of
emotional calmness so that you can
finally close that that that circle is
difficult to describe so I don't want to
try too hard to put words to something
which by definition if we're talking
about mystical experiences which is a
corollary to the durability of these
effects let me restate that in English
a little easier to understand when you
look at for instance studies that have
been done research that has been done at
whether it's Johns Hopkins NYU or other
places and I've gotten to know the team
at Johns Hopkins quite well and I've
huge amount of respect and admiration
for what they've they've done and
continue to do in many of the studies
whether they're looking at terminal
cancer patients and end-of-life anxiety
or they're looking at lifelong smokers
who came into a study specifically to
look at how psilocybin could be used for
the cessation of smoking the duration of
effect the durability of effect is very
closely linked to something that you
that you could refer to as a mystical
experience and it turns out as you would
hope there are different types of scales
and measurements one can use to
determine if something is a mystical
experience or not and there's some
debate about this but there there are
ways that you can assess whether
something qualifies as a mystical
experience based on looking at the
historical accounts and writings of
people we would consider mystics and one
of them is ineffability
hmm the inability for someone to
verbalize their experience that the word
somehow do violence to the experience or
don't do it justice Pollan gives a great
example of that in his book I believe it
was Michael Pollan in his book how to
change your mind about it you take
somebody from you know whatever a
thousand years ago put him in a time
machine bringing the time square let him
hang out for five hours
shoot him back can they describe what
they saw not really they could say that
it was big loud and bright but other
than that they couldn't explain what a
car is they couldn't explain what a
building is or a skyscraper because the
vocabulary hadn't even been developed
and that to me is like the greatest
example albeit somewhat glib of this
idea of being ineffable which is you and
I can sit here and talk about it in
shorthand but it's very difficult to
explain
to one of our friends maybe who hasn't
experienced this weed and and when you
you know again it's it these things
sound so so goofy when you say them like
these experiences you seeing yourself
from outside of yourself you know if
someone hasn't experienced that I can
understand why they would look at you a
little funny and say okay intellectually
I understand what you mean by that but
why would that matter why would that be
profound
how would that disrupt your ego it's
very difficult to convey and I would say
that what I've experienced and what I've
certainly seen and heard other people
experience in their reports to me and in
writing in various books that I've read
is the importance of the felt experience
and that in some senses it's not that
you have a psychedelic experience you
have three realizations you bring those
realizations back to this ordinary
reality you take certain actions based
on those realizations and based on that
intellectual legwork your life changes
it is not something strictly in the
domain of words and thinking and just
thinking harder and working harder in
other words you're not taking the things
that got you here if you've achieved
anything professionally or personally
the pro and con lists the spreadsheets
the logical arguments it's not that you
just get a better set of those things
that you bring back it's that you are
finally able to see and experience and
feel something like empathy deeply for
the first time for someone you've never
felt it for or you feel love for
yourself truly for the first time and
you think holy [ __ ]
like that's what's been missing I've
never even felt that and if someone had
asked me what a self love feel like I
wouldn't have had an answer for it these
are the things that really stick and I
think given the plasticity of the mind
or the plasticity of the brain that
allow is one researcher put it to me you
to instead of going to the top of the
ski slope and then taking the tracks
that have been worn and of course the
deeper the tracks get the heart
is to kind of hop out of them as you're
skiing but they get to the top and to
have four fresh feet of powder fall on
the entire mountain so that you you you
have the ability to choose an entirely
new path an entirely new record to play
it's hard to verbalize but one way to
think about it for me has allowed me to
come to grips with this because there's
a part of me that has sometimes thought
like this is too good to be true it's
gonna go away this newfound empathy I
have for person X or this reduction in
this horrible negative emotion I've had
that's going to go away in six months
and I and I've thought of something
which is when you look at the opposite
of that which is how often is a person's
life changed for the worse
based on one event and the answer is all
the goddamn time a child could be abused
once and that can change their life for
ever and again we're not gonna go into
that now because that is its own topic
but so many of the horrible habits that
we carry into adulthood are really
because we never became adults we are
basically adaptive children who are
taking on a set of behaviors to protect
wounded children and sometimes those
wounds occurred very acutely and so in
many ways these experiences with
psychedelics if administered correctly
in the correct setting with the correct
integration can act as the exact
opposite of a wounding event in other
words with something that is so acute
and so poignant you can just change the
direction of this trajectory this
vehicle doesn't necessarily mean it's
orthogonal and of course there's so much
more to it than that many people go
through similar types of abuse and they
don't all have the same impact and
similarly many people can experience a
psychedelic and not have the same impact
but I think when I started to think of
it in that way it started it started to
become much more understandable why this
could happen just as something horrible
could alter the course of your life and
you know I'm gonna one of the podcasts
I've already recorded that will be
coming out later this summer will be
with Corey who you and I spent a couple
of days with up at Kern
it's a maximum-security prison yeah when
we did this we spent this
this time up there with the five enters
the story of Cory's life is unbelievable
and it's just a again at no point in
their I think his Cora using any of
these things that happened to him when
he was young as excuses for the road he
went down but it's impossible to argue
that those experiences many of them very
acute in this moment on this day in this
place at this time completely set him on
a different path and he could have been
otherwise so as you said I love the idea
of this stage analogy because to me
that's actually one of the best
analogies I've ever heard about how
mindfulness meditation works is it's the
awareness that there is a stage that's
simply what it comes down to and to be
able to leave your vantage point as one
actor to step back and see that you are
an actor on a stage is I think one of
the most empowering things and that's
why I sort of love this interplay
between you know meditation and these
psychedelic agents there's an interplay
there's an interrelatedness there is a
reinforcement a mutual reinforcement
also which is why I'd love to mention a
few things just to give people a chance
to crack their knuckles and stretch for
a second in non psychedelic territory
there are a few things that I'd love to
suggest to people which help you to
develop the same types of meta awareness
that you can be thrust into through
psychedelics that serve a purpose
whether or not you ever choose to take
one of these compounds one would be
certainly mindfulness meditation and I
think by the time this podcasts are
recording right now is live Sam Harris's
waking up app I think it's just
tremendous I think it does an
exceptionally exceptionally good job of
this and there's certainly guided
meditations if you search say
mindfulness meditation jack Kornfield
Tara brach both outstanding sam harris
also has some some guided meditations
that he's recorded awareness meditation
and Peter you feel free to jump in if I
don't do this justice but awareness
meditation being different from say
other forms of meditation
many of which I have used and still use
on occasion perhaps one of the more
popular of which being say
Transcendental Meditation mantra based
it is a concentration practice where you
are repeating a mantra to yourself over
and over and over and over again as a
way to hone concentration and although
not everyone's gonna love this
description to give your psyche and self
a break from the incessant monkey mind
and you really can reach a transcendent
space where you feel like you are a
point of consciousness floating if you
do the 20 minutes twice a day very
consistently that is a concentration
practice if you were thinking of a
candle flame and that were a a focal
point for a period of meditation
whenever you found yourself swept up and
thought returned to a candle flame that
would also be a concentration practice
if you're doing there are many also
within awareness meditation there
different types but if you're doing say
something referred to as I think it's
sometimes called open monitoring where
you're paying attention to anything that
comes up as it comes up and there are
different ways to approach this but very
often begins with the breath so it is in
some sense a concentration practice but
you're focusing on the breath you're not
chasing it you're simply observing it
then you focus on sounds then you focus
on any discomfort or weight that you
feel in your body then you perhaps later
after 10 sessions 10 daily sessions
begin to practice with your eyes open
which I had never really done before
Sam's app which I found tremendously
helpful as a bridge into then waking
reality these are all practices that
help you to spot the gap between sensory
input and cognitive response and so that
you become more response able in so much
as you you have a tiny gap within which
you can choose your response as opposed
to simply reflexively going through life
like some type of slug that's been
shocked in a skinner box
thing yeah you you have more option
ality you suddenly realize there are
just more options on the menu then Oh
whenever so-and-so does this I always
get pissed off there are more options on
the menu and that by the way having that
basic ability having the just the ABCs
of that awareness and control will give
you a tremendous advantage and allow you
to get very often much more value out of
any psychedelic experience because you
will have had let's just call it 50
sessions on a boogie board before
they're like oh cool here's a surfboard
it's hurricane season have fun good luck
like maybe you catch a wave chances are
your first experience it's going to be
getting tumbled a lot and you can
accelerate the you can steep in the
learning curve really dramatically for
later getting more out of psychedelics
very often if you develop some of this
basic awareness beforehand I'm kind of
amazed at how difficult it is for me to
convince some of my patients at the
importance of meditation and I find
sometimes by just telling them about my
own struggles in my own journey to
accept first of all that this was
something that was beneficial even when
it didn't feel beneficial and to to
realize that you have to sort of figure
out what's gonna work for you but it's
worth making that effort I agree with
you I think that just even putting the
apps aside it's different people have
different ways of explaining things and
I remember a math professor I had in in
college and this was early this might
have been like I must have been I was
either a freshman or a sophomore but he
said something that always resonated
with me because now you were sort of
getting outside of like you know
rudimentary calculus and stuff in
mathematics were starting to get very
abstract and he said look if you're
reading a proof and you don't understand
it assume that the person who is
presenting it doesn't know how to
present it to you find somebody else and
so I think that that really holds also
for meditation which is there are just
going to be some people who guide in a
way that you're willing to be guided and
so you shouldn't be put off if someone's
listening to this thinking you know
every time I try meditation it doesn't
work
for me or something like that and and so
I don't want to sort of name the apps I
went through but there were many apps
that I went through that just didn't
resonate for me you know just the way
that they talked about this didn't make
sense to me but then when you find the
ones that do and there are several that
do for me including Sam's waking up
which you and I have been lucky enough
along with a number of other folks to
get the beta version of that which got
if it's been six months it's been a
while yeah I think I remember Sam giving
it to me in January the way Sam explains
it really resonates with me and there
are others that do so the same Jeff
Warren is also one of the guides on Dan
Harris's no relation to sam Harris 10%
happier I just love the way he explains
stuff and so you know I would say to
anybody who's listening to this who's
feeling sort of bearish on meditation
try a different app try a different
guide try a different book try another
way keep going till you find someone who
can walk you through how to do this in a
way that resonates and the others
mentioned to others since they're very
easy to test another is headspace the
ten and ten program I think is a very
very well done
format for beginning this it's ten
minutes a day for ten days and it's
quite well done calm for some people who
like the background nature sounds for
instance I've used that app and many of
my friends really find that to be with a
female guide to be their preferred mode
of meditation and then you can meditate
in silence you can consider taking a TM
course as I did which actually really
serves to kickstart a lot of my
meditation because it cost money so I
had that sunk cost working in my favor
and it's effectively for lunch breaks
over for days I want to say if I'm
remembering correctly and you have to
meditate in between those sessions so
you have homework and you are going to
feel like a doofus and a disappointment
and be embarrassed if you don't do those
sessions so you have someone holding you
accountable ie the teacher to actually
put this into practice for at least a
four-day period and that in and of
itself I pushed off for so
long for so so long and I remember Chase
Jarvis I'll give him credit again at one
point said Tim you can afford it it
worked for me what is the downside if it
doesn't work for you you still get to
meditate with someone else for four days
might that be worth it
and I didn't have a good
counter-argument so eventually I
acquiesced and took that step which was
which was very it was one of the first
times I finally felt what I had the
first-hand experience of what meditation
could deliver which is in some ways
equally difficult to describe as the
psychedelic experience when you have
your first session where you've
completely lost any rumination or
compulsive thinking about your to-do
list and it might just be the last five
minutes of a 20-minute session and you
come out of it and you just feel this
serene peace that perhaps you haven't
even touched on for 10 years you know oh
okay now I get it if this is something
that I could actually call upon reliably
that is a superpower and for that reason
I would say for that if you're going to
commit to this commit to it like you
would a workout program or a diet you
don't go to the gym once and come back
and wake up with in a six-pack abs the
next morning for me at least if I take a
break and there are periods when I
especially by the way if you eat like
we've eaten in Austin yeah we have in
there's so much good food here you have
to be very careful about portion control
but if you want to get a taste for what
meditation can do I would say commit to
10 days and for me at least if for
whatever reason I lapse and there's
certainly periods when I lapse this
happens to me a diet hab since it
happens to be with exercise and
occasionally you know what I haven't
meditated for two weeks for whatever
number of reasons it will take me I
would say 5 to 7 days to finally stop
grinding gears and shift into a calmer
state there it there's a certain loading
phase almost like creatine or something
there it takes
me five to seven days to click into that
different gear at which point I go oh
yes this is why it's so important now I
remember
yeah there's a great book out there
called altered states which I read this
year that I think does a great job of
parsing that concept out which is it
weighted states are altered traits
oh it's altered traits and it makes the
point that it's not about the state
thank you for that correction I've had a
whole bunch of people potentially going
to Amazon I can't find this book or
maybe there at that book does exist it's
completely the wrong book but that's
exactly the point right which is that we
don't meditate for the state the state
can be pleasurable I ought to be honest
I don't find it that pleasurable I don't
actually enjoy meditating that much
sometimes I do but but as many times as
I do I it's difficult for me it's work
it's sometimes truthfully it feels like
I suck like I'm boy it's really amazing
the frequency with which thoughts keep
entering my mind I think I forget who on
again I got I can't remember if it was
sam Harris or a different guide who made
this point which was actually I think I
think it was actually Jeff Warren which
was he described it as the bicep curl of
the brain is not the cessation of
thought it's the recognition of the
thought that then allows you to go back
to the breath or whatever the focus is
and boy that really again that's just an
example of like that's not a
particularly like profound difficult to
understand concept but it's exactly what
I needed to hear which is don't be
discouraged that you keep having
thoughts that's the exercise the
exercise is acknowledging it recognizing
it going back to the focus which in this
case could be the breath or a sound or
something like that and so it's not
about that state that you may or may not
achieve just as some people who exit
like you and I we love exercising so we
actually get a pretty good state out of
it I actually if exercise provided no
benefit I would still do it just because
of how I feel when I do it but for many
people that's not the case but exercise
is still valuable if you spend an hour a
day exercising it's really what it's
haploid is doing through that other 23
hours so that's I guess that would be
the next thing I would say to anybody
listening to this who's tried meditation
who has found it to be unpleasurable or
uninteresting or whatever
like that's okay you're not doing it for
what you experienced in that twenty
minutes I would also add and this just
just occurred to me because I think
you're you're in some ways alluding to
this that in my experience having
observed hundreds of thousands of
listeners and readers attempt or not
attempt succeed or not succeed with
different forms of meditation it's very
important and this applies to many many
different things including physical
exercise as far as as I'm concerned but
the good program that you follow I let's
let's lower it even further the
consistent program that you follow is
better than the perfect program that you
quit so if you're having trouble
following a meditation program and
you've committed to doing it daily which
is a very important commitment in the
beginning keep lowering the bar if you
think twenty minutes is too much do ten
minutes ten minutes is too much do five
minutes
if concentration meditation is too
difficult use a guided meditation and I
recall at one point there are two things
that I recall having been said to me I
think Tara brach mentioned the first I
could be misinterpreting but I think it
was Tara brach I first said this to me
her book radical acceptance by the way
ties into everything that we're talking
about beautifully it had a huge impact
on me and has had a huge impact on many
people it's the type of title that's
gonna scare off a lot of people cuz I
think it's going to be a bunch of woowoo
hand-wavy stuff there's a little bit of
woo in there but it is a incredibly good
book radical acceptance if you have any
type of emotional patterns or thought
patterns that seem to control you as
opposed to the other way around this is
a worthwhile book and her guided
meditations very good but we were
chatting a header on the podcast on my
own podcast and I believe was Tara said
the repetition if we're doing the bicep
curl
isn't the 20-minute session where you
sit perfectly without having a single
extraneous thought occur the repetition
is when you get distracted and something
comes up and then bringing it back
to the breath so you should be happy
when that happens because that is the
work mm-hmm the work isn't doing it
perfectly every time
it took me three years to understand
that yeah three years of frustration and
am I doing this right and you know why
can't I stop thinking and and just all
of this misunderstanding but boy once
you get what the bicep curl is it's
freeing and it makes the pass-fail bar
lower which for many of the people who
most need meditation which I think has a
brand Lima branding problem it should be
called you know emotional non reactivity
training or something that sounds very
appealing to you know type-a driven
people emotional non reactivity
conditioning program there you go
or just warm bath for the mind might be
appealing to other people but meditation
is such as it's a word that's becomes
it's so overused and unfortunately could
use a rebrand but for the time being
meditation and a successful meditation
session should in the be in the
beginning be as easy as possible to fit
into your life you need to stack the
deck particularly in the beginning and
TM transmittal meditation was very good
at instilling this in the training for
me at least they said if you say the
mantra once in a session that is a
successful session you have 20 minutes
to say a two syllable mantra once that's
a successful session and you might even
drop it further and say you know what
this is the goal this would be
miraculous but if I just sit for 20
minutes with my eyes closed that's a
successful meditation session and
sometimes I've honestly wondered how
much of the benefit comes from some of
the mental practices versus just sitting
still and breathing with my eyes closed
well that's actually really interesting
that that gets to something I want to
talk a little bit about which is the
study of psychedelics but while we're on
that topic it's it's hard to sometimes
study these things because of these
performance biases right it's hard to
disaggregate the effect of just sitting
there for 20 minutes and luckily some of
those experiments
have been done which is you know you
take a group and instead of saying the
control group just doesn't do anything
maybe you have the control group sit in
silence for 20 minutes and then you can
sort of disaggregate those things so Tim
you've spoken with me quite a bit about
your interest in funding science and
that goes back to even before the
discussion of psychedelics but very
recently you've made a pretty large
commitment are you comfortable talking
about that publicly I am I am very very
comfortable talking about publicly
I have almost entirely redirected not
just what I would have invested in
startups but a multiple of that into
scientific research I've made the
commitment for me which is by far the
largest commitment to not just science
but even any given startup that I've
ever made financially and that's a
million dollars a minimum of a million
dollars over the next several years
several meeting three or four and I
expect I'll exceed that one million
dollar amount with primarily a focus on
psilocybin and MDMA
but that could extend to other compounds
which which I also find to be under
studied and that have been in some ways
shelved for decades for primarily
political and not scientifically
justifiable reasons when we started
talking about this when you were
thinking about it I remember one of the
stories that you really liked was a
relatively unknown story in the world of
philanthropy unless you dig deep in the
annals about a woman by the name of
Catherine McCormack that story really
resonated with you what was it about
that story well you should you should
tell this story because I think it's
it's so noteworthy on a number of
different levels but what struck me was
how if time to write and if thought
about intelligently where you're
focusing on points of leverage how even
a single person with relatively moderate
amounts of investment and moderate is
relative right but let me rephrase that
how how someone or a small
group of people if concentrating on
points of leverage in furthering in this
case scientific studies can really bend
the arc of history in a way that most
people would find unbelievable
because when folks think of say Pharma
or bringing a new drug to market in the
largest-scale senses its billions and
billions and billions and billions of
dollars but that story was appealing to
me because on many levels but I'd what
I'd love to do is have you tell it and
then I will I will point out the the
parts if this were a kindle chapter
which parts I would highlight to go back
to to remind myself of certain things
but why don't you tell the story because
it's such a great example of what one
person or a small group of committed
people can do I'll leave it at that
well it can be probably be read about
more eloquently than I can restate it
but the gist of it was Catherine
McCormack in I believe the early 60s or
late 50s met a gentleman I believe his
name was Gregory Pincus if I'm not
mistaken and I think that's right at a
dinner party or yeah and and basically
he explained to her that he was pretty
convinced he could chemically synthesize
hormones that could be served as a birth
control pill or serve as a birth control
pill for women and she was no dummy
herself she went to it was MIT yeah I
believe have been involved with also
funding housing for additional female
students so they could attend yeah and
her hypothesis was if we could create a
birth control pill we could completely
change the interaction that women can
have with education with work with the
family balance etc now we take this we
listen to the story today and we think
well what's the big deal like so what
she funded the research for the birth
control pill but the reality of it is at
the time again I can't remember I must
have the dates wrong but certainly it
was long enough ago that this was viewed
as an absolute no-go
I mean there was simply you know birth
control was such a taboo
and what's really interesting is she
decided to fund something that was
incredibly risky that no pharma company
was willing to touch with a ten-foot
pole because it was viewed as just a way
to sink money into a bottomless pit that
could never achieve the regulatory
approval and using again a relatively
small sum of money and I believe in
today's dollars it's to the tune of
about twenty five million dollars she
sunk into the work of this guy Pincus
and I and one other gentleman whose name
is escaping me over the span of
something like about a decade yeah maybe
eight years and when you my favorite
graph that I ever saw which was kind of
the holy [ __ ] moment was the graph of
the number of women in graduate schools
professional School of Law School of
Business cool whatever pre and post the
introduction of the birth control pill
and it's you don't get to see a lot of
hockey sticks you know as one of my
friends once put it um
it's really cool when the data don't
need statistics to be analyzed it's not
like well there was a statistically
significant increase in the rate at
which women entered the workforce no no
like you didn't have to say the word
statistically significant it was a step
function change and I don't know I just
I I thought that was such an interesting
story and I remember when you and I were
talking about this a while ago I don't
know we even know why I told you the
story but you you seem to really grip to
it there were many reasons for it I
think partially being at the time in
Silicon Valley and surrounded by venture
capital I saw some of the stupidest I
don't know how else to put it just
stupidest non-viable ideas raise tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars let's just stick with
philanthropic dollars no or profit okay
startups repeatedly I mean you just saw
dozens and hundreds of examples over
time of this and it struck me that we
find ourselves in a unique time which
exposes something that goes without
saying every time is a unique time but
in the sense that long ago this is worth
discussing for a quick second
psychedelics specifically LSD were
through the controlled I think as the
Controlled Substances Act scheduled put
into the the Schedule one class of drug
classification which means high
potential for addiction no no known
medical or no medical application no
demonstrated medical application putting
them in the same class as heroin and to
be clear for the listener who might not
appreciate that even cocaine is
scheduled to write which means it still
has potential for addiction that
everybody acknowledges but it does have
at least one viable medical application
which is it turns out to be a pretty
good local anesthetic in the nose which
is ironic of course but it therefore it
does have a medical use and it's used
routinely in ENT surgery so if these
compounds are so useful if they can have
some of the effects without guarantee of
course it's not batting a thousand every
time if you have a hundred people on
random or using these some with
directions some without you're not going
to have a perfect record but if if even
some of the time the effects can be
achieved the outcomes can be seen that
we're discussing how did these compounds
including LSD end up in this category
and there it's a it's a multifactorial
problem and it's hard to say there's one
causal agent but there are a few things
that happened at the time number one
many people don't realize pollen gets
into this it's really fascinating but
lsd-25 which was first isolated or
synthesized by albert hofmann it was
developed on the part or on behalf of a
pharma company it was later used Roast
correct i want to say with Sandoz oh
you're right correct it was in and then
it was later used in a program that if
I'm remembering correctly was CIA led
called MKULTRA where it might be used as
a truth serum for interrogations and
things of this type or to confuse and
sabotage enemies of the state and it got
out into the wild and then the adventure
began so to speak
and LSD was widely distributed and at
the time you had parents who had never
experienced psychedelics we were going
into the Vietnam era and we had a number
of characters come on to the scene in a
very high-profile ways one of them being
and he cannot be even though he is often
given the blame I don't think it's it's
fair to do this unilaterally but Tim
Leary came onto the scene he was at
Harvard as was Richard Alpert who later
became Rahm Das and the things exploded
at Harvard and they they were both I
believe fired I don't think they
resigned preemptively because Sol Simon
was given to an undergraduate when it
was only supposed to be administered to
graduate students and at some point
Leary decided that science was too slow
and that the way to affect cultural
change was to have tens of millions of
people he had a specific number in mind
and that that would effectively lead to
a tipping point where all these positive
effects on society would be inevitable
and if you think about the cultural
setting you have a lot of young people
being told to drop out of school to
resist war efforts and all of that made
a number of figures including Leary very
high-profile targets that could not in
some ways be ignored by the
administration and so Nixon famously
said Timothy Leary is the most dangerous
man in America and you had parents who
could not in any way conceive of the
experiences that their children were
having on these compounds and that along
with dozens of other things was a recipe
for political crackdown which is exactly
what happened what you have now is you
have parents who are but in many cases
certainly products of the 60s who have
had psychedelic experiences you have
people who are in positions of power or
in regulatory organizations who have in
some cases experienced psychedelics you
also have studies now being conducted
even though
it's it's with great difficulty because
of all of the approvals and DEA
oversight and so on that's required that
are going back to the dozens and
hundreds of studies that were performed
before the the crackdown and
rescheduling and applying more rigorous
scientific standards and that is
combined with a number of as you
mentioned earlier epidemic level
problems that we're experiencing that
are costing I would have to imagine
billions upon billions of dollars namely
opiate addiction depression PTSD right
if you add up the costs associated with
those three if we want to be a little
crass about it and just look at the
profit loss it makes a lot of sense
based on the data thus far to explore
some of these compounds and that's part
of the reason why for instance in the
case of MDMA and PTSD the FDA has
granted MDMA breakthrough therapy
designation which means that not only is
the process expedited for ultimately
phase three trials that the FDA is in a
sense a collaborator so instead of
saying alright your methodology is
approved and I'm gonna apologize in
advance this is not Phase three trials
are not my area of expertise so if I
make any if I misspeak I apologize and
certainly feel free to correct me in
comments somewhere but the FDA is
effectively a partner who helps them to
navigate the entire process instead of
saying your methodology has approved C
in three years and you're gonna get a
pass/fail which is a precarious position
for any compound let alone something
that is currently scheduled the way that
MDMA is and we don't have to get into
right now there's also something called
special protocol assessment SP a which
should hopefully if the stars align in
some ways which I think they've very
well might give MDMA a very high
probability of ultimately being
prescribed 'el and with and used in
supervised settings it would not be a
take home drug in other words but PTSD
and specifically with respect to let's
say returning War veterans
or victims of sexual abuse is a it is a
highly bipartisan issue or I should
better say it's a nonpartisan issue it's
very hard for someone to say [ __ ] the
vets so the risk of of that getting shot
down politically I'm not going to say a
zero because it's never zero but it's
there are more attractive targets if
you're looking for re-election or
looking for press time there are safer
targets to go after to achieve that than
this and then within the scientific
community looking at psilocybin which
there are at least two entities right
now that are presenting Phase two data
to the FDA and I'm optimistic that
within the next year at least one of
them will proceed into Phase three
trials
psilocybin has has shown remarkable
efficacy at least based on preliminary
data for end-of-life or I should say
event based depression and people with
terminal diagnosis terminal cancer
diagnosis and that may end up getting
extended to major depressive disorder
which is to be continued to be
determined but I've already helped to
raise funding and also applied funding
myself to a study that will be looking
at treatment resistant depression at
Johns Hopkins utilizing psilocybin and
that means I believe by the book Dupree
onic depression that has failed at least
two interventions or two other
treatments are there other agents Tim I
mean loosely speaking and this is a
gross oversimplification and we will
probably get into a few of these time
permitting certainly as you said MDMA
has really shown pretty remarkable
efficacy in PTSD it's it's wild it's one
of those similar to the graph you
mentioned relate to McCormack yeah it's
just not subtle it's not subtle you
don't need the p-value to see that dunno
it's I think I'm getting this right
anyone interested can certainly look up
maps you can find them at maps org who
have spearheaded a lot of this but I
believe that psychotherapy alone
something like 27% effective at reducing
the scale measurement and I'm ad-libbing
a little bit here but let's just say
that there is a rating of zero
2:10 for determining severity of PTSD
anything above a three is PTSD something
along those lines this is a bit of adlib
but I think it's something between
twenty and twenty seven percent decrease
to below a three so they were no longer
they would no longer be diagnosed as
having PTSD with psychotherapy alone I
don't remember the time frame and when
psychotherapy wasn't combined with MDMA
was something like seventy percent I
mean it just not said a little so which
again we could spend just two hours just
talking about the role the relationship
of trauma and psychological damage and
how MDMA can help with that the other
thing of course which we talked about
very briefly earlier was I boga and
ibogaine in the treatment of opiate
addiction which probably has the worst
success rate amongst societal epidemics
that are being treated by conventional
means I mean there really aren't great
options for for the individuals with
with opiate addiction and then of course
psilocybin as you said on end-of-life
depression major depressive along with
smoking cessation
I heard it's even being looked at now
for alcoholism it is and there are a few
predominant classes people can look at
when it comes to psychedelics I believe
you have the there the tryptamines and
then the phenyl a means I believe it is
but we don't have to get into all that
partially because I'll just embarrass
myself but coming back to the default
node network which i think is worth
returning to for a second which
listeners might recall is this
collection of different parts of the
brain that appear to be active when you
are doing nothing what is doing nothing
mean and this was discovered I believe
in part when scientists were doing
calibrations within fMRI machines said
alright just do nothing we want to get a
baseline this is the part of the brain
that's writing what the hell is going on
and it appears to be highly activated
when people are engaging in any type of
self referential thinking I how does it
affect so not only like to think about
fear but what makes you fear what makes
you fearful okay boom and then default
mode network seems to light up any type
of temporal projection in other words
thinking about the past thinking about
the future
seems to also light this up and pollen
does a great job of digging into this in
the book and a number of people have
written about this in very eloquent
terms Robin Carr heard Harris out of the
UK is one of them but to do just pose a
question that I think is something
that's being explored currently if say
anxiety is being stuck in the future and
being depressed as being stuck in the
past
what happens if you're able to
temporarily suspend or deactivate that
system to some extent and to give
yourself that witness perspective so you
can look at yourself without being
yourself and the implication if many of
these psychedelic compounds are able to
achieve that is and even Tom Insel who I
think is the former head of the National
Institute on or of mental health ni mhm
if you look at OCD you look at different
types of depression different types of
anxiety and so on these are nice these
are very cleanly separated out and some
type of what is the the term for this
desk reference that people use for DSM
DSM in the DSM but they may all be
slightly different species of the same
thing which is why something like
psilocybin appears to be LSD very
similar story mescaline probably very
similar story at hide enough doses can
be used for anything that appears to
involve obsessive thought patterns or
behaviors that includes alcoholism it
includes smoking it includes opiate
addiction and there are studies that are
seeking funding right now I know at
Johns Hopkins related to opiate
addiction through the lens of psilocybin
treatment which I'm very very interested
in eating disorders like anorexia these
may in fact be very interrelated
phenomena and conditions so you
mentioned a few that are LSD I think is
off the table not for scientific reasons
but for political reasons it's just too
loaded there's too much baggage and
let us not forget that the media plays a
very large role in how politics respond
to things and in today's day and age I
do not have a high level of confidence
that LSD since it was once painted as
the villain is not it's too seductive I
think and I clicked bayit world to not
fall into the same bear trap in a way so
psilocybin then you have MDMA which is
thought by referred to as some people as
an enacted j'en or M pathogen this is
not probably not scientifically to
granularly accurate but it appears to
tone down that's not a scientific term
but tone down the amygdala and fear
response that we have to say recalling
or reliving traumatic events and it
allows us to people say with PTSD who
have seen their friends heads blown off
or had to blow other people's heads off
or whatever might be people have been
raped etc to in some sense clean up a
very messy experience that did a lot of
damage and to help people to heal
themselves in nonverbal ways this is
really key we it's it's very it's very
hard for many people to talk their way
out of something they didn't talk their
way into that's so well said I mean you
said in one sentence what I tried to say
in like 20 sentences a while ago about
the experiences that can cause pain can
be so jarring that it should be at least
acknowledged or considered that equally
jarring chemical experiences might be
necessary to put that new powder on the
slope definitely so you have MDMA MDMA
I'll be honest I was i I was biased in
some ways against MDMA for a long time
because a I didn't have much personal
experience with anything chemically
related to MDMA I had a fear associated
with it because of research which I
think has since been largely
he bunked in terms of risks for people
who are predisposed to depression for
instance it was also at one point viewed
as an and is still used recreational as
a party drug and I've I've really been
swayed to the other side I'm very
bullish on MDMA as a therapy I think
that it is extremely it's it's an
extremely powerful and flexible tool
that does not entail the type of
perceptual distortion that some of these
psychedelics do which is not to say I am
NOT bullish on psychedelics I am but it
requires much more sophisticated
training to administer so MDMA I Booga
and I began going back to MMA I do think
it is important to point out if
anybody's listening to this thinking
well of all of these compounds MDMA is
pretty easy to get and you know it you
can get it packaged in other things and
it's ecstasy etc but this goes back to
intent setting and integration I really
do not I am not convinced that just
taking MDMA going to a party is somehow
going to unwind any of these problems I
mean it's really I would go further than
that and I would bet against it yeah if
someone gave me a hundred grand and they
said all right this person is gonna take
MDMA to go to a party ten times what is
the likelihood that it's going to fix X
long-standing problem I'd go a hundred
thousand dollars every single dollar
against yeah I would shorten it and I
know people in fact who have used MDMA
recreationally and then used it in
supervised settings and it is as if they
are taking a different drug yeah that
just can't be overstated and I'm not
just saying that because I'm a doctor
and I'm supposed to say something
responsible but I I mean that regardless
it's and that for me is the urgency
around this stuff it's I I think about I
think about myself frankly but I think
about my patients and I think about a
lot of my patients that would benefit
from these things that I've experienced
or even things that I have an experience
that I've seen people experience and I I
just I've never had such a sense of
urgency around this I mean prior to this
the most urgency I ever had was waiting
for pcsk9 inhibitors to come on the
market when I read that first paper in
the New England Journal of Medicine
about
twelve years ago on the discovery of
this type of you know these these
individuals who had missense mutations
in that enzyme that lowered their LDL
significantly but boy the the anxiety
the anxiety might be the wrong word but
the anticipation I had for that class of
drugs which anybody listen to me this is
probably falling asleep thinking that's
you're an interesting guy if that's what
was keeping you up at night waiting for
that drug but but this takes it to
another level which is almost nobody I
know has not been traumatized on some
level and it doesn't always have to be
something that is so obvious so you know
we've all been traumatized we've all
sort of been hurt we're all dealing with
these things and yet I feel how quickly
can these things go through this
regulatory pathway to get into the hands
of people who would know how to
administer them I certainly wouldn't
write even if these things were legal
today that's only half the battle
it's can you create enough practitioners
that know you know how to select the
right patients and how to apply the
treatment because this is in many ways
harder than any other treatments we have
today you know people talk today about
the importance of combining
psychotherapy with antidepressants but
that's really the tip of the iceberg
compared to this stuff and it's it's
also tricky from a commercial standpoint
in so much as part of the reason these
compounds haven't been picked up like a
football
yeah and run to the the end zone by Big
Pharma is that many of these studies
only involve two or three sessions with
psilocybin yeah naturally occurring
molecule in these cases it's synthesized
but there's a lot more money to be made
in something that you can charge an arm
and a leg for that you have to take on a
daily basis or an every other day basis
indefinitely as opposed to two or three
times with some pre-work and post work
with durable effects in many cases that
that's financially an unattractive model
to many people and I think it's a
mistake there are some for-profit
companies out there I should say
startups who are going after this and
I'll be very disappointed if they try to
make their money on the molecule by
blocking other people from doing
research or manufacturing and good
manufacturing
in GMP facilities and so on rather I
think they should make their money on
the services on the therapy so that's
that's maybe a separate discussion
now why his ibogaine taken the longest
track and why is that still the one that
seems to have gained the least traction
for testing in the United States I've
spoken to a number of people
philanthropists who are really
interested in this opiate addiction
problem and yet they are understandably
not interested in funding research
outside of the United States and
basically their view is until the DEA
and the FDA allow for a similar pathway
we're not interested in funding this and
I worry that there's a bit of a
stalemate there is that this is this
thawing I don't think it is yet to thaw
there are some researchers and a
blanking on names I apologize but there
are a number of researchers who are
doing very good work looking at I began
and have been studying it I boga and I
began in the United States part of what
makes ibogaine tricky if on one end of
the spectrum you have MDMA which again I
don't consider a classical psychedelic
but as a tool that can be applied to
some of the same conditions
what makes MDMA attractive is general
low toxicity relative ease of
administration short duration if we're
looking at I want to say four to six
hours let's say maybe a little bit
longer 48 hours ibogaine falls on the
opposite end of the spectrum
no I before we get to what puts it on
the opposite end in spectrum I should
say I know people very directly who had
family members who were heroin addicts
and say prostituting themselves I mean
on death's door if they weren't going to
die from an overdose they might die from
getting shot in the street and in in a
case like that where nothing else has
worked including some say alternatives
like methadone I've seen cases where I
began has worked
I mean don't the practitioners of this
offer that at one year the recidivism is
only twenty percent I don't know the
exact numbers but that's given what else
I have seen with
these compounds that we wouldn't I don't
find that unbelievable yeah if I'm
recalling that's only with two weeks of
of intervention now these are people
that are put into a you know a very
heavily supervised detox environment
where the the eye booger and the
ibogaine itself are administered over a
one-week period
outside of the you know pre and post
integration so I think the entire
therapy if I recall is about six weeks
there are there in many different
formats and I know people who have been
involved with running some of these
clinics and certainly they're people
like Gobber or Ma Tei who have we've
looked at opiate addiction very closely
but ended up as I understand at least
looking at ayahuasca and others for
helping people who are addicted to
opiates ibogaine is very it's it's
unlike some of the others such as
psilocybin in that it acts on a whole
slew of different receptors and let's
discuss what puts it on the opposite end
so it yes it can have these seemingly
miraculous effects on opiate addiction
and part of the reason for that
experientially is I understand it and
I've never gone for a full ride I began
or I booked a psychedelic experience and
I have no desire to it is very
unpleasant it is very long so it can
last as I understand it and people could
feel free to correct me but 24 to 36
hours that is a long time and many
people experience a full review of their
lives and a controlled death experience
whereby they get to see from the
beginning of life almost like a
slideshow the decisions they've made how
they've hurt themselves the other people
they've hurt how their addiction has
affected things and what government they
would how he might frame it is instead
of asking why the addiction asked why
the pain and the addiction is often a
response almost inevitably but often
response I'll say often to some type of
trauma or pain and if you don't address
that in some fashion allow people to
reintegrate that somehow the likelihood
of recidivism is very very high so just
from a phenomenal
nah man illogical perspective which is
bantha I'm saying it's a subjective
experience standpoint many people report
that biochemically and there are people
who are looking at for instance using a
metabolite of I began nor ibogaine which
may mitigate some of the risks and this
is this is part of the reason why I
began hasn't taken in their risk I think
we've stated were sufficiently Hardy is
cardiac arrhythmias people have and can
died of cardiac events in using I began
I don't know the specifics but I believe
you can screen for this in a number of
different ways to minimize the risk and
then certainly you can monitor an way as
having other types of more conventional
pharmaceuticals on hand in the case
there is some indicator of a pending
cardiac event or cardiac event itself
that's one of the major risks it is one
of the more potentially dangerous
psychedelics it almost certainly is be
compared at least say LSD or psilocybin
for which I don't believe there is a
known ld50 meaning well you could
examine this better than I can
yeah they all d50 being the dose at
which 50 percent of a population would
receive a lethal dose exactly
biochemically what I was gonna say this
putting putting all that stuff aside for
it for a moment what's so odd about this
and I'm not an opiate specialist but
I've had family members die from opiate
overdoses I don't even know if I told
you about this relatively recently and
my best friend growing up on Long Island
also died of a fentanyl overdose so I
have first-hand experience with the pain
of losing loved ones to this epidemic it
appears that many people can come out of
these ibogaine treatments with close to
no physical withdrawal symptoms and I
don't know how that works
I really don't but it does seem to be
certainly one of the constituent pieces
of this experience that lead to the
success rate that many people are
reporting which is really interesting
because it's true that opiate addiction
opiate withdrawal is not
physiologically harmful
alcohol withdrawal is so delirium
tremens so these DTS that people get
when they were draw from alcohol will be
fatal so you actually have to manage
these people with benzodiazepines and
other medications as you tape or someone
off you don't have to do that with
opiates but the withdrawal is
nevertheless psychologically devastating
so that's interesting that you could
mitigate that I've read accounts where
people talk very similarly about
ibogaine the way you described or the
way I thought if it was you or if it was
Michael Pollan on the podcast talking
about the smoker I think it was Michael
Pollan talking about the smoker who says
you know my lungs are just too beautiful
to be insulted with this stuff and like
I realized that in America and it's like
as silly as that might sound to someone
listening to it that experience if
profound enough can have a have a
life-changing event that is durable and
that's what the key is the durability
and similarly I've heard these I've read
these accounts of people who you know
have been completely addicted to
narcotics
you know the account I'm thinking of in
particular was it was someone using
heroin and they came away from this
thinking I could never stick that needle
in my arm again like I could never do
that to myself again because I now saw
this connection I have to a plant and or
another person and or another organism
and again I I know that I realized that
when I say that it sounds really silly
it takes this or brings us full circle
in a sense also back to the beginning
when I said that you shouldn't and you
don't have to go through life simply
tolerating yourself at best
because there are a thousand things that
could follow because but in part if you
don't have any regard for yourself if
you think you're worthless or if you
think you're fatally flawed if you think
you're a [ __ ] if you think you can't
get anything right or you just don't you
don't have some intrinsic love for
yourself you don't see any beauty in
yourself why wouldn't you be addicted
why wouldn't you stick that needle in
your arm why wouldn't you smoke pot five
times a day and tune out why wouldn't
not to say there aren't applications of
cannabis don't freak out people out
there
it's an interesting space we don't have
time to get into it right now but there
are so many ways you can numb or damage
yourself which is a in some ways a
logical coping mechanism if you have a
low regard for yourself but when you
sense an interconnectedness and you
suddenly have empathy not just for other
people like we've felt through our
experiences but an empathy for yourself
you look back at like the ten year old
Peter or the 10 year old Tim and I'm
just like Jesus Christ [ __ ] poor kid
I mean and I can sit with that feeling
and actually identify with that kid and
forgive that kid and assure that kid
everything's gonna be all right it's
right now in words through this
microphone probably not going to have
the impact that I would hope it to have
but for people to feel that as if you
are in the same room with that younger
version of yourself can be
transformative beyond anything that I
could convey right now and when you have
an experience like that as ludicrous as
it might sound the idea of injecting
some type of numbing agent into your
body just becomes inconceivable in that
in the same way that it would be
inconceivable as you mentioned earlier
how you treat yourself is ultimately how
you would treat others like what would
you is like inject your son with that
you're like to numb his experience of
life of course not yeah that was just
one of the most powerful experiences I
ever had when I really finally accepted
all of the issues I needed to accept and
go into therapy was something they made
me do which was carry around a picture
of me at a certain age before certain
things that happened that were pivotal
in sort of shaping both the positive and
negative aspects of my personality and
the idea was at and again it just works
out that way it worked out that way for
me that my oldest son is at about that
age and just for what it's worth looks
like me so it became a very easy way to
look at him and say well that was me
and it turns out that that was the that
was the bridge to understanding it's
very it's actually if you're a parent
what parent can't find em
for their child and that's like this
stepping stone and so to think that
these agents can do that because maybe
not everybody has that luxury of having
a child or having a child that looks
like them at the same age when they were
traumatized or something like that I
mean it's it's very powerful and you
know just I guess it's there are many
problems to which I really honestly have
no it not even the foggiest clue how to
go about solving them from a practical
standpoint like like talk about climate
change like we could talk about climate
change all day long and we could
certainly wax philosophically on the
lots of regulatory things that could be
done to mitigate it but you start to
realize very quickly that politically
these things become challenging and you
have all sorts of different economies
around the world and they'd all have to
be in lockstep and and and you sort of
not to be dismissive of these things or
say we shouldn't work very hard at
solving these but the solution space
isn't that clear to me and yet when you
see a problem that in my mind is the
single most important problem that's
plaguing our civilization and I know
that's a big statement that's a super
big statement and I realize it's also
probably naive when you consider that
there are many other problems going on
but unhappiness is at the root of more
pain I would suspect than any ailment
that falls in the quote-unquote physical
body and to think that we have compounds
that could play such an important role
that are really facing you know
challenges and getting approved I just
find that really frustrating it's
frustrating and it has been frustrating
for people like for instance rick doblin
who heads up maps who've been he's been
at it since 1986 1986 which is just two
main problem before hand if you take
into account I believe that that's when
maps was officially formed if I'm not
getting my facts wrong and we're at a
very exciting time now where MDMA is
being expedited psilocybin is certainly
on its way for people who are interested
in learning more about this I think maps
org is a fantastic place to to
look in fact one of the areas where maps
could use support as I understand it is
in taking their approach to legitimizing
MDMA use therapeutically in the US to
Europe so there will be steps they'll
take with the EMA I think it is which is
the FDA equivalent in the EU for
hopefully facilitating MDMA use in
Europe so that that certainly if you're
looking to become involved with
exploring and potentially supporting
this as I am that is one clear and
present need and it's it's we're also a
very exciting point because psilocybin
is one example which has a lot of good
research to support it there's a lot
more being done at places like Hopkins
and NYU and many other places now may
have and this remains to be studied but
it's plausible that it could have
profound applications to opiate
addiction for instance and it this comes
back also to the McCormack story with
birth control because the I don't recall
what the first compound was that was FDA
approved but it wasn't approved for
birth control I think it was approved
for menstrual disorders that's right
that was the thin end of the wedge was
women whose menstrual cycles were
unusually heavy or uncomfortable or the
first approval exactly silt and that's
the most important step is it's much
easier to use something off-label once
it's been approved than to get something
approved right you pick the right
indication and that's what's also
impressed me about these organizations
is just the strategic thought they've
put into this which is understanding a
roadmap that is interested in the least
resistance right because - what does it
take to reschedule something if you want
to take it from the same class as a
heroine and put it into a class where it
can be prescribed with proper
supervision medical supervision you need
to do well you you you one of the
approaches like cocaine and the
the hazel anesthetic demonstrate one
clear medical application and if that is
depression in terminal cancer patients
that is a legitimate medical application
and then that entire train can get in
motion that's one nice thing about where
the DEA and the FDA fall out is for the
most part there's a sense that look once
we've as these agencies done our job in
scheduling something we're going to put
faith in the practitioner to use his or
her judgment as to how much latitude to
grant around the application and and
I'll also mention one thing just in case
we have regulators or lawmakers
policymakers people within the FDA or
DEA who are listening and that is read
pollens book check out pollens book and
immerse yourself in this fascinating
area of research and I'll give if like a
lot of people you just don't have the
bandwidth to dedicate a lot of time to
this a something that pollen has
referred to on a number of different
occasions and that is the addictive
potential so what is the addictive
potential of these compounds we're
looking at say psilocybin specifically
we could use other examples but if you
take a rat put it in a cage and you give
it one dispenser a little a little lever
that they can push to dispense food and
another dispenser with cocaine that it
can use to dispense cocaine it will
consume cocaine to the exclusion of food
until it dies in many cases if you do
that with food and say psilocybin and it
gets delivered a whopping dose of
psilocybin it will press that lever once
that's like okay that was enough and it
goes to the food and that rather than
having high addictive potential many of
these compounds have anti as we've
already discussed anti addictive
potential and my god it's it is
terrifying when I look at where I grew
up on say Long Island and you look at
the obvious put putting aside the all
the stuff that I don't see or hear about
but
the obvious among people I grew up with
among my friends who have died of
overdoses family members who have died
of overdoses these are in some cases
educated people in some cases not they
are using prescription medications these
are widely distributed easily prescribed
medications that have demonstrated
incredible abuse of potential and to
think that we have these molecules that
can be produced at at relatively low
cost at scale that are not just
non-addictive but anti addictive really
provides some hope that we can
counteract some of these incredible
epidemics I mean I you might have been
the person who told me this could have
been someone else but was it last year
that opiate deaths exceeded automotive
accidents yeah for it used to be that
automotive accident was the leading
cause of death for people up to a
certain age and I believe the age is 40
and now opiate overdose has offset that
so you know this isn't an isolated issue
anymore you know for me I think I I
think the rate limiting step is actually
going to be training the clinicians to
administer these things I think that's
going to become the bottleneck and
that's why I hope that you know you know
and we we have friends who were
psychiatrist psychologists who have
become very interested in this and that
to me is really heartwarming because
they're actually going to be among the
people who need to lead the charge on
this yeah there are groups thinking
about this certainly both maps and other
organizations that are involved
psilocybin are thinking about this
people who have come to the table to
provide some funding like myself and for
instance the Bronner family of Bronner's
soap and others certainly they're
technologists who have who have come to
the table many of many of them have done
so anonymously are very well aware that
having these compounds legalized for
supervised to use is step one and that
there will be a very very real need for
training clinicians and the wheels are
already in motion with prototyping some
of this there's a there's a group called
CI is out of California which is
prototyping some some training protocols
or therapists who are licensed in
various ways already so that when these
compounds are available through
prescription that there are trained
clinicians who could administer so we'll
see we'll see I'm very optimistic but
this is where I will be applying a lot
of my focus and these problems do not
they do not discriminate these problems
these addictions depression anxiety that
people experience on a daily basis don't
care what color you are don't care what
gender you are don't care how much or
how little money you have I mean given
how publicly I've talked about for
instance the content of the TED talk
that I that I put out there on the
depression I've had people come out of
the woodwork from my listenership my
readership some of the wealthiest people
in the world who suffer from
debilitating depression whose kids are
addicted to heroin and then on the
opposite end of the spectrum people who
listen to the podcast who were just
scraping by same set of issues
debilitating and you know for the in the
last few years I've I've developed a
real sense of optimism about myself and
my life quite frankly number one is a
starting point which i think is a
starting point before you try to save
the world it's a good idea to try to
save yourself and I have come away
completely convinced that many of these
stories I told myself which were
crippling were unnecessary and that they
can be wiped and you can write new
stories new narratives for yourself and
we talked about meditation there's a
book you introduced me to then I think
we should we should certainly mention
also just solve for every solve for
happy can you talk about this yeah so
Rick Gerson who is a mutual friend and
you actually introduced me to Rick
probably about five years ago he gave me
a copy of this book and it was one of
those things that just sort of sat there
for I don't know six months and it was
just in the queue but didn't you know I
didn't really appreciate why I ought to
read it as soon as it was given to me
you know something in the midst of a
crisis sort of brought it to my to my
attention a little more quickly and I
just devoured it and so if if the
Terrence real book I don't want to talk
about it has now jumped into the number
one spot of books I've gifted most solve
for happy is probably in the number two
spot and little guy at yep I'm not sure
if I'm pronouncing that right but mo
lastname gaawd eighty you know and then
and that's sort of pushed mistakes were
made but not by me into the the now
number three spot
just ahead probably of surely you're
joking mr. Feinman it's weird it's an
interesting it says something about us
the books we like to give people doesn't
it you thanked Michael Pollan at the end
of your interview or maybe it was
somewhere in the midst of it but I
thought it was at the end of the
interview for writing the book that he
did because you said it was the book you
wanted to read and that you wish you
could have written but you're no slouch
yourself when it comes to writing books
is there is there anything that if you
if Michael hadn't have done that and you
would have been writing that book in
addition to all the stuff we've talked
about the day is there anything else
that you would have included in that
book that that wasn't included and
that's hard that's a hard he's a tough
act to follow
oh very tough act to follow and I'm so
pleased that he wrote the book because I
have been very clearly biased in the
sense that I am a I've seen the power of
these compounds firsthand and I'm not
shy about as we've seen in this
conversation putting myself clearly on
the side of support I don't think they
should be available at every 7-eleven
some people think it should be every
every drug should just be available for
anyone wants to pick them up at anytime
I disagree with that positioned
completely but I am nonetheless
exceptionally bullish on the scientific
research and ultimately the rescheduling
and widening of making these compounds
available to people through qualified
professionals and supervision Michael
has such a pedigree and is so widely
respected as a and I don't think he
would mind me saying this a skeptical
highly skeptical investigative
journalist that I'm I couldn't be
happier that
he published his book before anything
that I might write on the subject if I
were to write a book about or including
I should say a discussion of
psychedelics it would differ in along
the lines of pollens and my writing
styles meaning Paulinus is so brilliant
at taking the history and science and
characters in a given field and weaving
it into a first-person narrative of his
exploration of all of those things much
like John McPhee I don't want to digress
he's also just a hero of mine but
they're both so good at that I would
never try to out pollen pollen I'll get
I'll get my face ripped off my book
would just be a poor poor poor imitation
of something that he would do best for
masterfully you know as I'm writing a
book now sorry to interrupt it makes it
that much more apparent to me when I
read good books how much I suck and I'm
not saying that in a it's not a negative
self-talk although it sounds like it's
just the reality of its like look I mean
these people are great for a reason and
it's it's exactly what you said it's
like the best books are not lecturing
you they're bringing you on a journey
and when when they can do that in really
complicated topics and bring you along
and also interweave history nonlinearly
that's yeah oh it's it's it's amazing
but I would say just to give you a
smooch on the forehead that much like
the best meditation approach or app or
teacher in the world for me
may very likely drive you nuts and is
not the right person for you that
stylistically some writers some books
will speak to you or grab your attention
in an otherwise overflowing workload and
somewhat and that differs person to
person so rather than trying to out
pollen pollen or out McPhee McPhee for
God's sake that would be a losing
attempt I've realized that I'm not what
I enjoy doing is providing first-hand
accounts of myself experimentation
followed by prescriptive recommendations
that aren't intended to work for
everybody but that serve as more of a
choose-your-own-adventure buffet of
options that I have vetted to at least
work on myself and a number of close
friends who span some you know different
genders different age groups and so on
and that's what I did with for our body
that's what I've done with all these
different books so if I were to write a
book including psychedelics it would
likely include experiments with other
modalities other vehicles other tools
that also produce not minutely
noticeable but profound changes in
consciousness which is really the stage
upon which everything happens right and
in doing so provide you with an
opportunity to rewrite the story of your
life or to gain perspectives that are
otherwise inaccessible and that might
include sensory deprivation tanks it
might include neurofeedback it might
include other types of non psychedelic
pharmaceuticals it might include
ketamine for exact adding we did four
incidents today that would have taken a
while but yeah ketamine is a whole
separate kettle of fish and I I think my
book would be more diffuse in that sense
somatically connected but with
independent modular chapters that
includes some likely extreme experiment
that I conduct on myself and then report
back and say I guess what I pushed the
envelope and went way too far so you
don't have to let's dial that lets dial
that back 80% and here's something you
can try that I think has an acceptable
risk benefit profile that's probably the
book that that I would write speaking of
your books I don't know if I told you
this story I think I did but if not it's
it's worth retelling totally unrelated
to this but it just made me think of it
so like maybe a year ago or so I'm in
the airport and I just remember like my
flight was delayed and I was sort of
like a friend who I don't talk to that
often like maybe once a year he called
me and he's like dude
I just read about you in a book today I
think I know where you go and I was like
I was like uh really I what do you mean
he's like yeah yeah you you're in this
book it's called biggest tools and I was
like what he goes yeah yeah like there's
no chapter on you in this book and I
mean oh do you mean tools of titans he's
like yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it
that's it and just kept like he just
didn't even and it was just and he's
Israeli and he has like an accent so
it's like you could tell that like the
expression biggest tools didn't mean to
him what it meant to me I just thought
that was the funniest thing so to this
day I feel like proud to be one of the
biggest tools well you know that would
be maybe the alternate title of the the
podcast that you and I have joked about
which is dumb things that smart people
do and that's a separate conversation
but there's so many ridiculous habits
and obsessions that anyone who could be
considered smart has if you have not
seen it already just where some people
find egg boxing I will link to it but
there's it's got its own Facebook page
at this point it's hilarious that'll be
a teaser I do have one final question
that's not on the topic at all of what
we've discussed but given that we have
now between the two of us in the past
two and a half hours drank I want to say
20 topo Chico my bladder right now is
probably at its maximum capacity I think
pretty soon I'm gonna develop
hydronephrosis so we're gonna have to
bring this thing to a close one of the
questions I get asked all the time is
you know people say oh you're such good
friends with Tim like does he still do X
does he still do y he wrote about this
he talked about this I wonder does he
still do it and so I was thinking for
the person out there who's sort of
wondering like what how is Tim evolved
when you think of all the things you
have written about when you think about
all the lessons you have codified for
people what are the three four maybe
five things that you have written about
in some of your books that still
consistently shape how you have
continued to optimize
trajectory so the three to five things
that I would say I returned to most
reliably are perhaps unsexy to some
people but one would be some type of
hinging exercise movement
I noticed that problems crop up when
these are emitted for any extended
period of time by hinging movement or
hip hinging movement I mean some type of
deadlift or kettlebell swing two-handed
kettlebell swing very very simple to
incorporate that into an exercise
program I do not believe unless you have
some type of competitive agenda that you
need to do these more than once a week
you can certainly do them twice a week
for extra credit but kettlebell swings
or deadlifts once a week prevent a whole
host of issues and improve a whole host
of performance factors so be one number
two would be fasting and entering a
state of ketosis for at least one week
at least once a quarter in conversations
with Peter and conversations with Dom de
Agostino is a mutual friend very
impressive not just published researcher
and scientists but also athlete himself
the intermittent use of auto foggy and
entering this state of fasting and
ketosis seems to me to deliver a host of
potential benefits with very minimal
downside I also like the just the pure
asceticism of the practice so we have
the hinging movement like a deadlift or
kettlebell we have fasting plus ketosis
for an extended period at least once a
quarter I just actually finished my
latest segment about a month ago number
three would be some type of meditative
practice first thing in the morning I'm
also asked constantly one of the
questions that I ask sometimes which is
what advice would you give your 20 year
old self what advice you to give your
thirty year old self and it would be
meditate ten to twenty minutes first
thing in the morning don't do it after
you check your email and do a B and C
because you're going to fail 50% of time
you just will
not go back to it wake up right now for
instance I have a foldable chair that
goes on the floor I believe it's called
a back jack or a jack back something
along those lines use quite often in
meditation centers right on the floor in
front of my bed that faces out a window
looking at a bunch of beautiful trees
and I get out of bed throw some water on
my face sit down and meditate and I
would say that's number three absolutely
is some type of non reactivity training
we were 10 to 20 minutes or put another
right nonreactive 'ti rehearsal which is
another reason why meditation sessions
where you're you feel entirely scattered
and you only return to the breath a few
times feel like a waste of time but they
are absolutely not a waste of time is
that there are going to be periods
throughout your day on many days when
life is gonna just roundhouse kick you
in the face over and over again and you
are going to be in that scattered state
so it is good to rehearse mindfulness in
that scattered state which is exactly
what you're doing all right so we have
the hip hinging movement at least once a
week exercise wise ketosis last fasting
meditation would be three number four
would be the importance of group ritual
and this is something that very often
falls by the wayside that I forget
because I've so often retreated into
myself whenever I felt pain or
depression or anxiety I don't want to
impose that on anyone else and I feel
like I should be able to figure it out
on my own and just climb back into the
cave that is my brain and this very
often results in isolation where I'm
just by myself even if I'm surrounded by
other people by myself sitting in a
coffee shop by myself in my own head
group dinners at least once or twice a
week cooking I have found and this was
not always the case for people
interested you can check out the 4-hour
chef for all the reasons why I find this
so incredibly therapeutic but you don't
have to cook I just happen to find it
adds a new another level of
decompression but group meals at least
once or twice a week would be
number four and then if I had to pick a
number five I would say I'm not gonna
use the psychedelics because we've been
talking about this entire conversation
if you feel like you're having trouble
making yourself happy try to make
someone else happy and I think that that
is the workaround that very often then
improves your own state so it's like if
you're feeling just awful or depressed
or in a funk it's like go get a coffee
and pay for the person behind you I mean
just exercise some of those random acts
of kindness think about someone who has
helped you and call them and leave them
a voicemail and get them on the phone a
thank them for how they've helped you
and closely related to that that ties
back into the meditative practice is if
the mimimi practice focusing on your
breath focusing on your thoughts
focusing on your your your your me me me
me is maybe exacerbating some of your
problems and you feel like you're having
trouble escaping your own head take a
look at Metta meditation m ET ta also
known as loving-kindness meditation and
I have found that to just be powerful
beyond belief I didn't think it would do
anything I found it kind of cheesy I
thought it was kind of cliched I wrote
about this a bit borrowing from the
teaching of someone named Jade Ming tan
who was an early engineer at Google and
created a class called search inside
yourself which was hugely oversubscribed
by employees at Google I think it had
some insane waiting list and this was
one of the techniques he recommended so
loving-kindness hyphenated
loving-kindness meditation which jack
Kornfield has some some fantastic
examples of jack Kornfield
kor Enfield and loving-kindness
meditation also known as meta M et ta
meditation and there have been multiple
reports I've certainly experienced this
myself but by doing Metta meditation say
at night before going to bed do that for
a few days and you might have the most
at peace week you have experienced in
years it's it's really something else
it's worth experimenting with
so I would say those are my five at
least the the five that come to mind
right now that I would feel very
comfortable defending and backing well
Tim that's super helpful because I we
managed to somehow figure out a way to
spend so much time together that I when
you say those things I'm like yeah of
course like we that's just what you're
always doing so but I think it's great
for people who are listening this who
don't you know get to interact with you
frequently who to get that little update
on stuff so you've been in Carly
generous with your time but what people
probably don't realize is how generous
you've been with your time off this
podcast including sending me the links
to like which pieces of equipment to buy
for the recordings and sitting down with
me and giving me the not just the 101
but the you know the full course on luck
do this don't do that waste time and
energy on this don't waste time and
energy on that so I really want to thank
you I can't imagine having anybody else
be the number one episode of this
podcast and I I do hope that this
podcast continues beyond the the initial
twelve or thirteen but even if it
doesn't this will have been incredibly
worthwhile and thank you again for your
hospitality this weekend in particular I
remember I put out something on
Instagram the other day about what was
the over-under on how many top o Chico's
I could drink in a weekend then I think
I said it at 15 or 16
we have blown through that I can't
imagine I do I still don't to this
anyone who's listening this who doesn't
know we're talking about we're talking
about is sort of bottled water it's in a
glass bottle and it's a it's a
carbonated water but anybody who's tried
it will agree it's not like a Perrier
it's not there's something different a
little touch of magic sodium to keep you
coming back for more among other things
[Laughter]
anyway Tim I can't thank you enough for
taking the time to be on a little
rinky-dink podcast at this point but
anyway it's been it's been wonderful oh
my pleasure man I expect to see you
right up there with with our mutual
friend Jocko who you introduced me to so
thank you for helping to unleash Jocko
on the Internet and ever since our
episodes on my podcast where I had you
on as a guest I've been beating the drum
wanting you to start your own because I
think that you're just going to do a
fantastic job and then it's going to
become
one of the regular listens in in my own
rotation of podcast and I listen to so
keep it up in thanks brother hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by Walter
Isaacson's number one New York Times
best seller Leonardo da Vinci they're
clinicals the life and times of the
renaissance genius while showing us how
we can harness the Vinci's boundless
curiosity and creativity
not long ago I interviewed Walter on
this podcast about his writing and
Leonardo as I've known Walter for some
time and the book is spectacular I think
it's his best biography yet and that is
really saying a lot considering how
famous and popular his BIOS are of
Benjamin Franklin Einstein and Steve
Jobs Leonardo da Vinci the book that is
has been hailed by the New Yorker as
quote a study in creativity how to
define it how to achieve it
end quote and it is based on thousands
of pages from Leonardo's astonishing
notebooks and new discoveries about his
life and work so Walter really reveals
an intimate Leonarda we get to know
sides of whom we haven't seen before in
a narrative that connects his art to the
science he shows how via an artist
genius was based on skills that we can
improve in ourselves
such as
passionate curiosity but how to hone
that careful observation how to develop
it and an imagination so playful that it
even what secluded with fantasy but at
the end of the day was imminently
practical Leonardo da Vinci by Walter
Isaacson published by Simon & Schuster
is available now wherever books are sold
and I suggest you check out an excerpt
at da Vinci bio.com
that's da Vinci bio.com this episode is
brought to you by peloton which I've
been using for about a year now peloton
is a cutting-edge indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right
into your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated there
also up to 14 new classes added every
day with more than 8,000 classes on
demand and you can pick based on length
45 minutes 20 minutes whatever music hip
hop rock and roll or say low impact vs.
high intensity or interval you can pick
the class structure and style that works
for you and in my case I quite liked mat
wilford's and I tend to do on demand and
listened to a lot of and watch many of
the same classes over and over but I'm
kind of promiscuous and also enjoy
classes from a lot of the other
instructors they have peloton and
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or
in any way incentivize me but they
really 100% hit the nail on the head I
was very very impressed with how
motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
comm that's fo and e peloton PIL OTO
and.com and enter the code Tim all caps
at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your Paul's own bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want
check it out go to one peloton calm and
use the code Tim to get started
you
you